- So I imagine you have
these grandiose ideas
and this concept that you have.
And there's a guy there that is like,
"I am here to scale you back down."
- Yeah.
- It's like, you're pushing the envelope
a little bit aren't you?
- It's like I wanna record on the moon.
- Apparently a dying black hole
or like a black hole is
like the loudest sound ever.
The moon would be nice,
but I don't think I'm gonna.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
- Lads, lads, lads.
Welcome back to another episode
of the "Trash Taste" podcast.
I'm lad number one,
and I'm with lad number
two and three as always.
And I've got a lad sitting next to me.
Who are you?
- Ah.
- Just a lad, bro.
- I'm just some fucking guy.
(laughing)
- We just found an
Australian guy on the street.
- Yeah.
- I was like, I thought
I was the only one.
- No, no, no, not today, not today.
- So after many, many months,
many, many moons,
we finally have the one
and only Mr. Kevin Penkin
on the show.
- How's it?
- Hell yeah.
- Aside from being just an Aussie lad,
what else are you known for Kevin?
- Not much mate.
(laughing)
No, okay.
So I guess like on a good day
I write music for anime and games.
Some of those-
- On a good day.
On a bad day, I'm just
some fucking guy on a couch
drinking a beer and watching YouTube.
(laughing)
But-
- Who isn't?
- Hey, actually yeah,
it's not a bad day actually.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- On a professional day,
I am writing music for anime
and video games, as I've said,
some of those being "Made In Abyss",
and "Tower Of God",
and "The Rising Of The Shield Hero",
and also did the "Star Wars:Visions",
one of the episodes of
"Star Wars:Visions",
which-
- Oh yeah.
- Not the worst thing to happen to,
I guess me.
I don't know.
- Are you being modest?
- Composes for "Star Wars",
not the worst thing to happen.
- Not the worst, yet.
- Not the worst.
- That'll be my like on my tombstone,
"Not the worst."
(laughing)
- I think the thing that
is like, always like,
'cause I've never asked
you this, I'm just like,
how the hell did this happen?
- Yeah.
- Like, how did you do this?
Cause it seems like Japanese animator
would wanna get Japanese composers.
So like how did this all come around?
- And I guess they have for
the longest time, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- What's your like background
with music and the life,
and how did you end up here.
- Well, it's, I mean,
it's a very super random
like kind of series of events
that I don't really
understand how it happened.
Happy it did,
but I have no idea
actually how it happened.
But I guess like the
chronological events is that
I actually started working,
probably, yeah in the end of my teens,
I started working with the
"Final Fantasy" composer,
Nobuo Uematsu.
- Nobuo Uematsu, wow.
- Yeah, which is awesome.
- How did that happen?
- Okay, sorry let's go back.
- Wait, no one just like works
with Nobuo Uematsu, you know.
- Lets go back to the conception.
- Yeah.
- Your local neighborhood
friend, Nobuo Uematsu.
- You know.
- I just saw a guy in the pub
and I just ended up composing
with like the composer of "Final Fantasy."
What?
- I thought you said conception,
I was like, ah, well.
So yeah, I had always like wanted to do
like video game music.
I remember cause my first
game console was GameCube
and I played this game
called "Metro Prime",
which is still my favorite game.
- Amazing game.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, it is one of my favorites.
And when I played the game,
I was like, I wanna do that.
And so that's basically what happened.
I was like, oh, I want to do that one.
- Right, right.
- And so I kind of just
like started, you know,
pretending to write video game music.
And Australia also had a bunch of like
video game concerts that happened,
including the "Final Fantasy" concerts.
- Yeah.
- But in a slightly different,
did you just burp?
- No.
(laughing)
- I thought I heard this click thing,
I was like-
- He has a clicking thing so.
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay, well I shut the fuck up.
- Did you interrupt my story?
- How fucking dare you?
(laughing)
- But, I fucked up the story a little bit.
So I fucked up my-
- It's good, restart it, restart it.
- So yeah, Australia had all
these kind of concert going on
and I met a conductor called Arnie Roth
who did some concerts called "Play".
And so I went over from
Perth, Western Australia
from where I'm from,
went over to Sydney to do this,
to kind of view this concert
and he invited me to come say hello to him
and also one of the composers there
who's the "Silent Hill"
composer, Akira Yamaoka,
so I met him.
- Right.
- That was really cool,
and he was like super kind of,
he was very, very generous with his time
for like some eager, you know,
piece of shit 15 year old.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- So I really appreciated
that even to this day.
But because I met Arnie,
when I saw that when Uematsu san
was gonna come to a concert
in Seattle, one of the places.
I was like, Hey, so we might come over,
like me and my dad like might
come over and come say hi.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And they were like,
"Oh, well thank you for coming
such a long way from Perth."
Which is like 36 hours in a plane.
Don't recommend that by the way.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, something like
36 hours going to Seattle,
met Arnie and then he was like,
"Oh, just come to the dress rehearsal
"and come say hi as well
to Uematsu and stuff."
- Wow.
- So yeah.
- So you're just going to these concerts?
- We went to that one, yeah.
- You could just say hi?
- Well, because we met at
that previous one in Sydney
we were then able to
come over and stuff, so.
- Right.
- Yeah.
It was very, very lucky.
- Yeah, you make it sound very easy, like.
- So you met him initially
and you just bumped into him initially
or you like-
- No, no.
So like we had been invited to come say hi
at this concert in Sydney,
which then led to this concert in Seattle
where Uematsu san was where
we met for the first time.
- Right.
- And Australia, all the school sort of
all the school years are flipped
because it's summer when it's winter.
- Right, okay.
- Because it's Australia.
- Yeah.
- It's Australia, yeah.
Everything's sort of, yeah.
- Of course you gotta
flip it like physically.
- Our summer holiday is December.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so that's when we have like the
classic school, like two, three months
kind of break sort of.
- Right, right, right.
- It's basically like all
of December and January
is just off.
- Yeah.
But that was obviously
like New Year's and stuff
and Christmas in Japan.
So for summer holiday, we
would go to winter in Japan.
And they very graciously say hello,
yeah, you can come say hi and stuff.
- Yeah.
- Eventually that just led
to a couple of, yeah,
it's not the "Final Fantasy" game
I should be very clear about that.
- Right, right.
- Right.
- But yeah, I was, yeah.
- But you made some
pretty insane connections
from that I bet.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's still pretty
crazy to talk about, but it's-
- Yeah, you make it sound so easy, like.
- You know, just like had
them on speed dial after.
- I just went to a concert
and then just went to another concert,
and then just, you know,
things happen and then,
yeah, here I am.
- Honestly, at the end of the day
I'm just happy it happened.
I mean, I know I've been using
that word a little bit today,
but it's like, yeah, I'm just super,
just things have just panned
out not so shit over the last-
- Right.
- I'm trying to piece the whole
thing in my head together.
Like-
- Me too.
- How it all (laughing).
How it all comes together.
So you met him again at another concert?
- Yeah.
- And how did that translate
into then working for them?
Because surely that's a massive leap.
- Well, because of these Japanese trips
that I would do over Australian
summer, Japanese winter,
basically what happened is
we were able to just
kind of keep a connection
and then eventually,
like I kept on submitting
some CDs and stuff like that.
- Oh wow.
- Right.
- I was that guy, so.
But which in this case it worked out.
But you know, it's like,
you never think about it that way.
You're just hoping the
best to just, you know,
just wanna be involved in some way.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Feels nice.
- But you just like kept
submitting your work
and they're like, okay, okay.
- I mean, like God bless
them they actually, you know,
listened to it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which they had no obligation to do.
I would not hold it
against them to not do it,
but they so graciously kind of did
and eventually I'm happy to say that
I was able to be useful to them,
so that's yeah.
- So you were like making music
from like as early as like how old, like?
- Oh shit.
- Like I assume very, very young, right?
Like, were you like classically
trained and stuff or?
- Yeah, so I played flute,
I came from flute.
- To see you playing flute,
it's such a funny image to me.
(laughing)
- I can do the "Anchorman" solo.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, I can do it.
- Why didn't you bring your flute today?
- Yeah.
- Sorry, I left it in Melbourne.
No, I actually like picked
it up a little bit last year,
like during the pandemic.
'Cause I was like, oh,
I'm fucking bored now so.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Tried again and ended up using it a bit
on the new Shield Hero and stuff.
So I did some jazz flute.
- Oh.
- Wow.
- Stuck that in, you stuck that in.
- Hell yeah.
- A cheeky jazz flute.
Little cheeky jazz flute.
- So you started with
flute from like earlier on,
and then you kind of
just went off from there.
- Yeah, flute playing,
play Metro Prime when it's right music.
Just like played on, I'm not
sure if you know "Finale?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I did "Finale" for
a little while and like,
didn't understand what like
working with actual, like
you know, DAWs and stuff,
which are digital audio works.
- Digital audio workstations.
- Yeah, it's like Logic
Pro and stuff like that.
- Yeah.
- And Logic Pro is
eventually what I moved to,
I'm still use it today.
And-
- It's the scariest thing.
- Yeah, it's all right.
- It's very overwhelming
when you look at it, yeah.
- [Connor] I was like, what the fuck?
- I know nothing about audio.
I'm that guy today.
I'm like the Connor of this episode,
I'm like, yeah,
that's letters that you
are saying right now.
- I know more for once.
- For once, yeah.
- Well, hate to say it,
but Connor was kind of right
with the whole beeps and
boops thing a little bit.
- Oh, are we getting into that already?
Yo.
- What, what?
No.
- Yeah.
I hate to say it,
but I like that noise
is the most accurate way
to describe how I feel
about music as well.
- You're a literal musician.
You do this for a living.
- Oh my, my life has been a lie.
- Dude, like I remember
when Connor first brought up
the whole like beeps and boops shit,
I was like, don't worry,
eventually when we get Kevin,
he'll be on my side.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, I won't lie,
I like opened a bottle of gin
and just started drinking
after that phase.
I was just like,
what the fuck are you guys talking about?
At the same time I was like, to be honest,
like yeah, maybe we'll go into
like a little bit more detail
about why the noise is nice,
but the not, yeah.
- The noise is nice.
- Yeah, I mean.
- That's it, that's it.
It's just I like the things
my ear is feeling, you know,
I like hearing the noise.
It's just a soothing.
- But we should explore why,
we should explore, why?
- What?
- Why.
- Why, why.
- That's a level that
he's never crossed before.
- Yeah.
- I dunno.
I feel like it's the most primitive way
of experiencing music.
Like the way that it was just meant, like.
- Is there any other
way to experience music?
- Well, 'cause everyone want to add this
super kind of like deep art meaning,
and I'm like, noise is nice, you know,
like it's just saying like.
I don't listen to a piece of
music and feel any emotion.
I just take it in and I'm like,
this feels awesome.
- No, I mean, we all do,
but we also it's that plus
alpha for us, you know, like.
It's not just the alpha, all right.
- Yeah, best way maybe
to describe it's like,
okay, so noise is nice,
but the noise is nice because like
certain things that are working together-
- Right, right, right.
- Make like said, nice noise.
- Yeah.
- This is why I brought you on today
to explain this concept.
- In the most monkey way possible.
- Not stupid way like I would explain.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well I mean, 'cause like,
it's just made up of like random kind of,
what's the word?
I guess sort of categories.
So it's like, you got
melody, you got harmony,
you got rhythm and stuff like that,
you got texture,
texture is really, really important.
Texture is like, it might-
- What is texture?
- Texture is the sound
quality, the sound quality,
the quality of a sound.
- That's like-
- You sounded like an alien right now.
It was like,
"What is this texture
you humans speak of?"
(laughing)
- I don't normally talk to musicians,
and normally when I hear
someone talk about texture
it's with like food,
or like with things that
you feel with your hands.
- Same concept.
- Yeah, same thing, yeah.
- It's the exact same
concept it's like, okay.
Fuck okay.
Okay, you know the, I
think it's "Billy Jean",
you know the (beat boxing)
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- The drums.
- Yeah, so the drum sound
is super distinctive
because anyone can play that beat
and anyone can play that
like a drum like that.
- Right.
- But why do you know
that it's that fucking song straight away?
Because the sound of the drum,
the textural quality-
- Beeps, the boops.
- Specific and unique.
- Right.
- So that's the whole idea of texture.
Like texture, I think is criminally,
not criminally and I can't pronounce
that fucking word right now, but.
- Primitively.
- Yeah, primitively underrated.
No texture is like, I guess,
I would call it like kind
of the secret ingredient,
even though it's not
that secret and you know.
- It's the spice that you add
to make it all come together.
- It is all salt and pepper.
- Right, right.
- With many spices.
- Yeah.
- I see like we've inadvertently like
separated the musicians on one side
and like the apes on the other side.
- It's got like a glass panel here,
like don't fucking come near us.
- Yeah.
- Is this how you feel
like when we talk about anime?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I get it now, I get.
- Okay, so you started, you know,
doing, you know, writing
music from a young age,
you met Nobuo Uematsu.
So like how did you then
go from like that to,
oh, now I'm writing music
for "Made In Abyss"?
- That's-
- Cause like, I feel again,
that's like not like one
step process, you know.
- There were a couple of steps.
- So, so, so, okay.
Number one, how did you learn Japanese?
Because I assume you would
need to learn Japanese
to work in the anime industry.
- I mean, obviously I'm not, yeah.
I'm not this beautiful
boy when it comes to that,
but you know, I feel like I do fine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like I do well.
And so yeah, I learned Japanese.
In Australia there's
this thing called TAFE,
which is sort of a-
- A community college kind of thing.
- Yeah, it's community college,
like sort of a non-
- Not university.
- It's like you could treat it
as like a pre-college almost
that sometimes do like
certificate level stuff.
So it's like bachelor, certificate.
- Right.
- Sort of underneath that.
- Yeah.
- So I did that.
So I went to school at the
Western Australian Academy
of Performing Arts,
WAAPA as it's called.
- Yeah.
- Whopper.
- So I went to WAAPA for three years
doing composition there.
- Yeah.
- And that was in Perth.
But then at nighttime,
I'm trying to imagine me doing this now,
like gonna school during the day
and like go to school
- School during night.
- Like I do not have that energy.
- Congrats on being 30 by the way.
(laughing)
Welcome to the club, Kevin,
welcome to the club.
- I am tired.
(laughing)
So I can't even use the
jet lag excuse anymore,
but oh well.
No, so I went to this TAFE
school on like Thursday and a,
wow, let's try that again.
Tuesday and the Thursday.
- Yeah.
- Tuesday and Thursday.
And on the middle day, the Wednesday,
I would go with all the classmates
that like I was learning with
and we would go to this seedy
fucking bar in Northbridge,
which is like kind of like the,
I don't even how to describe it.
It's the-
- Seedy part of Perth.
- It is the like club
crazy like seedy, you know,
glue sniffing sort part of Perth.
- Right, right, right.
- Was it real Perth?
Like I've heard a lot
of things about Perth,
every Australian I've met.
And one pattern that I've seen
from every Australian I've met from Perth
is that they no longer
live in Perth anymore.
- Yeah, I know four people, including you,
who are born or raised in Perth
who are no longer in Perth.
- Yeah.
So like, I would say that
if you've grown up there,
there is like a certain, like,
I wanna call-
- Shout out to our fans in Perth.
- Look, there is a certain like
jovial sort of jokey aspect
to like saying, "Oh yeah, I'm
from Perth, fucking what."
- Yeah, yeah.
- But like once you leave,
I think there is like a
little bit of homesickness.
- Oh, of course, of course.
- I haven't been back in a span
and I fucking miss it so much.
- Right, right.
- I might be there for
two, two and a half weeks and be like,
"Yeah, I'm cool."
- Yeah, you've had your fill.
- Bye Felicia.
But you know, until then
I'm pretty homesick.
But like, yeah.
So we went to this bar in Northbridge,
'cause Perth is super, super popular
with working holiday Japanese people.
- Oh really?
- Super popular.
- Oh, I did not know that.
- Japanese people love coming
to Perth and that's great.
For what it's worth,
even though I just like
kind of described like a-
- I'm just like, yeah.
I'm trying to wrap my head around
what the reason that might be.
- Joey, like I've never seen
that facial expression on Joey
where he tried to understand
either his Japanese side
or his Australian side,
and he is just like,
there is something that's gone wrong.
- Both my Australian and
Japanese side were like,
that sounds like a lie.
(laughing)
- As far as I can remember,
it's not, but it's in Perth.
- I wonder why though.
- Honestly, sun.
Sun and beaches.
- Right.
- Yeah, and wine.
Lots of wine.
- That's why they don't
come to the UK, huh?
Do we really hear about Japanese people
in London that often.
- No, not really.
- Of course, like it's also very far away,
but I guess so is Australia
now that I think about it.
- Yeah, Perth's pretty fucking far away.
- Well, I mean like nothing.
- Yeah, yeah, that's true.
- There is a connection
between Australia and Japan.
There's quite a lot of
sister cities and stuff.
And obviously it's like sort
of the Australasia region,
sorry if that's triggering for y'all.
But no, the Australasia
region is obviously yeah,
I think there's a lot of,
I mean pre COVID of course,
there was lot of like
kind of travel treaties
and stuff like that.
Yeah, working holiday visas were rampant.
For lack of a better word.
- Definitely.
- But we would go to this bar
and all the working holiday people,
'cause it was a shitty bar,
but on a Wednesday night it
would be international night.
You got $10 jugs,
which is like, I think like,
seven pound, or like 8.5 American dollars.
And yeah, you just get fucking wasted
with awesome like working
holiday Japanese people.
And cause obviously when
you're a bit toasted,
your language confidence,
especially a language you can't speak.
- Of course.
- Somehow it just raises up.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, and so you would almost have
like the two formal
training days on each side.
And then you'd have like the-
- The real training day.
- The toasted night, yeah.
And your brain would
just like sponge it up
and figure it out.
Yeah, that's how it started,
and then actually like since COVID,
we've been doing a lot more
like kind of business meetings
and stuff on Zoom and stuff.
And so like, my keigo has like
gone way through the roof now
because I almost exclusively speak like
sort of with that,
I almost treat it as like a buffer.
Almost feels like a buffer like,
if you're not like not sure
how to speak to someone,
using the keigo almost
feels like I'm just like-
- Being safe.
- Yeah, yeah, safety.
- Right, right, right.
- You dunno where your
like relationship is,
you just have to speak polite.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's like, I'm just gonna avoid any like,
you know, faux pas,
like being overly polite.
- Right, right.
- I did notice that actually
'cause like a couple,
was it a couple of months ago
that we did the "Made In Abyss" event?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, I co hosted like
a "Made In Abyss" event
for "Made In Abyss 2"
and obviously Kevin wasn't
there like in person,
but he was on like a Zoom call
'cause there was like a segment
where we were talking about
the music for the show.
And you know, obviously
because it's a Japanese event
live stream to a Japanese audience,
Kevin had to speak Japanese
for the entire part.
And you know, I hadn't heard
Kevin speak Japanese in a while,
so I was like, oh, you know, hopefully,
you know, he'll get through it.
And I was like, damn he's
keigoing the fuck up.
Like I was like,
he's like way too polite
in this entire thing.
He's like talking to the
fucking prime minister levels.
(laughing)
I'm like, he's just talking
about like the music.
- Well, the problem is
'cause I've almost like
lost the middle ground now.
So it's like way too casual
or it's way too formal.
- Right, right.
- And I was like,
because it's like something,
something, something.
Instead of saying like yes or something,
I'd be just like yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well that's just like
you in a nutshell, right?
Cause like one thing you'll
realize meeting Kevin is like,
he's like the most humble and nice person
like you've ever met, you know.
But then that is until like
he starts getting like a few pints in him.
You can always track how drunk Kevin is
by how much more Australian he is.
So at the beginning of the night,
you're like,
you might not even know that
he's Australian or something
'cause he's like way too polite.
- Kevin is either extremely professional
or extremely unprofessional.
There's no middle.
(laughing)
- That doesn't sound like me.
I don't know what you're talking about.
(laughing)
- Give me a lighter.
- Yeah, oh that's a flip.
- Cause you were saying like,
I definitely experienced
that this weekend, right.
'Cause you know, obviously
like during the convention,
you know, we'd go out and
have a couple of drinks
and all that kind of stuff, right.
And it's like, you know that Friday night
where we're out, you know, drinking
and we got that Burger King
at like two in the morning.
- Oh man, you're bringing that up?
You want that to be committed to YouTube?
- Yeah.
Because like, you know, Garnt
was saying like, you know,
you know Kevin is drunk
because he just gets like
exponentially Australian, right.
And I think that Burger King night
was the most Aussie I've ever heard Kevin.
- I was so bitter about that burger,
it fucking sucked.
It was so shit.
- That's Burger King.
- Yeah, I know.
Like first, it was fucking
2:30 in the morning.
I was like, there's only so
many old fashions I can have.
- I'm not expecting you to
make great decisions here,
I'm the same.
- So to explain, it's
like 2:30 in the morning,
obviously everyone's
like drunk and you know,
everyone's starting to get
a little bit hungry, right?
So there's a Burger King there,
Kevin comes out with like a bag full of
what he thinks is like
just a light snack, right.
What he pulls out of the bag,
it's like the fattest double whopper
that I've ever seen in my life.
He pulls it out of the bag and he is like,
in the most Australian way,
he's like, "What the fuck is this?"
(laughing)
And he's like, "Oh fuck
it, I've already bought it.
"It's all whatever."
- So just like, this is
like goes back to like
that fucking iza kaya thing
where I ordered too much
'cause I just fucking hit buttons.
I just hit the button.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- You're like, this is an amazing idea.
- Yeah.
- I can handle all this.
- So, so, so to explain-
- So much ambition.
- The last time we went out to Japan,
we went to an iza kaya
and then Kevin was like
pretty hungry, you know.
We started drinking before,
but Kevin was like-
- Oh, this fucking time.
- Yeah, we were hungry,
but we also like just like
little bit tipsy and Kevin thinks
you know what's the good idea?
If I order one of everything on the menu.
- A four page menu,
in fact it was four page of
menu for just the chicken,
and it was like four page
of menu for like pork.
- It was like an
onslaught, it did not stop.
- I've never had to like,
it's a fucking all you can eat.
Like you can just do it.
But like at the same time I was like,
I had to talk to the fucking staff member
and be like, can you stop?
- Can you stop.
- Any food that you have not
physically cooked yet, stop it.
- Cause it was like,
there was like 15 different livers.
And I'm like, how do you
even find this many livers?
I'm just, I'm done.
- You know, there's salt fish.
- So like, we learned that
day if we go to an iza kaya
and there's a tablet there we could order,
never, never give it to Kevin
'cause he's just like, "Oh,
what does everyone want?"
And everyone's just
like, oh, just whatever.
And Kevin takes that too
literally as everything.
- But like, because you know,
I think it's just because like, you know,
I haven't been back home to
Australian in a while, right.
And like, you know, I have a
couple of mates in Australia
who are like very, very ocker,
but like, you know, Kevin is
like next level Australian,
especially when he is drunk.
So he was like-
- A little bit, a little bit.
- Yeah, so like, you know, going back,
he like unwraps the double whopper, right
'cause he's like, he
already has it in his hand,
he takes like three bites out of it,
and he just goes, "This is shit."
(laughing)
"This is so shit."
- I think I remember that.
- What was shit about it, do you remember?
- It was so dry, it was like so dry.
- It was so dry and it was so heavy.
- Yeah, it was like,
oh I fucked up okay.
Because like in Australia
we don't have Burger King
we have Hungry Jack's.
- Hungry Jack's is good.
- Yeah, so it's like, you know,
if Burger King was like better.
- It's good.
- Yeah, like Hungry Jack's is like,
I would argue way, way
better than Burger King.
- Yeah, but like, but not by much.
- Not by much to be fair.
- Sorry.
- No, no, no.
- I dunno if I'm crazy,
but I swear Burger King,
don't they like drench it in like sauce?
- I wish.
- 'Cause it's so fucking dry?
But the burger is like the most like
skeleton esque burger ever.
- Yeah.
- Like extremely anemic, yeah.
- You could snap the patty in half.
- Yeah, I had the chicken
like there was like a long
chicken burger type of thing.
And it was like,
it was so it was like freeze dried,
it was so fucking dry.
I was like (choking)
- Yeah, yeah, it was a bad tactical error
that we will hopefully not make again.
- But it's just so hilarious,
just Kevin raging at a double whopper
at 2:30 in the morning.
- I've got a good friend
back home, I remember,
'cause I took him to
this like really like,
there's this Ankara Bakery thing on,
it's called Beaufort
Street in Mount Lawley.
- Beaufort Street?
- Yeah, there's an Ankara
Bakery on Beaufort Street,
in Mount Lawley in Perth.
What I say?
- Beaufort street.
(laughing)
- Beaufort.
- Sorry, I'm sorry, I'm a child.
- All right, all of our
eyes just like gleamed,
like Beaufort?
- I'm gonna blame the dry London air.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not very successfully, but anyway.
Beaufort Street in Mount Lawley in Perth
and like, they do like really good kebabs,
like fucking amazing kebabs,
but my friend was not a fan of them.
I remember 'cause he said the same thing
and he tried to throw it out
and it exploded all over his car.
(laughing)
So this egg just fucking went
all over his body and shit.
(laughing)
- At least he tried to
throw it in his car.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I don't know why I brought that up.
Well there's food rage,
there's a lot of food rage.
- So perhaps back back to your music.
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
- This is the process.
- Been inspired by dry burgers.
- Fucking shit burger and go
write some fucking angry music.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
♪ This burger fucking sucks ♪
(laughing)
- Oh my God, musicians.
- Yeah.
- What do you call like
a track in "Shield Hero?"
Just like dry chicken salad.
(laughing)
- Going like more like psycho
with the naming conventions
recently, so that might-
- I'm waiting for double
whopper at 2:00 AM.
- Double whopper and fries.
- Double Whopper.
- The name's only if you're
like the soundtracks, right?
If you're in the show,
you could just make-
- No, I mean, if you're
doing like an OP or ED,
they do have in the opening
credits to say like you know,
composed by blah, blah, blah
arrangement done by blah, blah, blah.
- Used these tracks,
"Dry Chicken Sandwich" by Kevin Penkin.
- "Dry Chicken Sandwich"
OP, insert anime here.
He was never heard from him again.
- No, 'cause I did notice
in some of your tracks in "Shield Hero,"
like I think the first "Shield Hero",
there were like some weird names in there.
- Yeah.
- Actually I'm gonna get it out now.
They were like some of like
the usual suspect names
of, you know, like generic
animate music names.
- Yeah, I know what's coming.
- So you go through this soundtrack list,
and most of them are
like, you know, normal.
You know, you have a track that's called
"The Rising Of The Shield Hero."
- Of course.
- The titular title.
Of course, you know, you have like some,
you know, isekai type track
called like "Game Start"
and stuff like that.
And then you go down
to like near the bottom
and then there's a track
called like "Spirit Bomb"
and I'm like, huh?
Was that like a cheap
"Dragon Ball Z" reference?
Probably is, it's Kevin, okay.
We can get away with that.
And then you're just like,
"Boom, Boom, Boom."
(laughing)
You're like, Kevin, are you
kind of running out names?
And then you go down even further,
and then there's a track
just called "Noms."
(laughing)
I listened to the track and I'm just like,
this name has nothing to
do with the track at all.
And then you go next
there's like "Mattyboi".
- "Mattyboi".
- Who's Mattyboi?
Who's Mattyboi?
I want to know.
- I can actually explain this.
I can't explain the "Noms",
I'm out on that one.
(laughing)
My bad on that one but-
- That was the 2:00 AM chicken sandwich.
- He was like, I could really
go for BK right now, "Noms"
(laughing)
- What was the first one you said it was?
It was, oh "Boom, Boom, Boom".
Have you watched "The Interview"?
Like with Franco and Seth Rogan?
- Yeah.
- The one that like got so
many hacks by North Korea?
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, no, 'cause like when
they finally like shoot down
Kim Jong Un in the movies,
I spoiled that again.
Fucking Franco's character
just goes, "Boom, Boom, Boom"
and he like fires a tank
bullet into the helicopter
and that's the reference.
- That's it?
- That's it.
- What's that got to
do with "Shield Hero?"
- Fucking nothing.
- Is it even like a booming track,
it's just like?
- I don't know.
I think so, yeah.
No, it is a little bit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like a battle thing on.
- Checklist, it was like 50 plus tracks.
- [Kevin] That's the whole idea, yeah.
- That seems like excessive almost.
- Well, I mean, cause it
was 25 or 26 episodes,
so that required.
So basically what happens,
as I'm sure you all know,
but just for clarity and
all that sort of thing.
So there's normally cores.
So one core, two cores.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Core?
- Like a season kind of.
- Oh, oh, oh.
- So one core is 12 or 13 episodes.
- Oh okay.
- If it's two core,
it's like 24, 25, 26 episodes
or something along that length.
And so for example "Made In
Abyss" season one of course
is like 13 episodes so it's-
- One core.
- All right, all right.
- But "Shield Hero" had 26
episode, you do two core.
So normally for two cores,
you don't double the music,
but you probably play 1.5 times it.
- Right.
- Okay.
- So for "Made in Abyss" the season one,
I think the soundtrack comes
in at one hour and 52 minutes,
something like that.
- Right.
- And I think it's about,
I think that was actually
about 50 something tracks
or like maybe 40, mid 40 tracks.
- Jesus.
- Yeah.
- But then "Shield Hero" yeah,
it was about 60, 62 tracks
and it was about two hours
and 50 minutes of music.
- And is that like left up to you,
do you decide how many
tracks you're making?
- No actually.
- Or are they like,
hey, we need 62 tracks,
make them all sound different.
- It's actually pretty specific.
So what basically happens is
when you get commissioned
to write anime music,
you get just basically
a massive Excel sheet
called the music order.
- Yeah.
- So when you get the music order,
it's basically, yeah just like
it'll have like M1, like music one,
and then it'll say like main theme.
And then like M2 will be like
main theme happy version.
And then like M3 three will be
main theme dark version or something.
- Right, right, right.
- M4, main theme hero version
or something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Just quite generic
sort of like descriptions
and they might have some explanation
or they might have some, you know,
some visual images and stuff like that.
So you actually get a lot of freedom,
which I really, really like.
- Yeah.
- So if you think about how like,
'cause they'll have all that sort of thing
and then maybe once you get
to like M20 it'll be like,
battle one speed battle,
or like battle two, like serious battle.
- That's literally,
that's all they give you?
- Sometimes, I mean, we can
get very specific as well
but like it'll start
from that sort of like
slightly more abstract sort of approach
which actually really, really cool
because that way you
actually do have a lot of,
kind of, like I said, freedom
to actually just try to
explore different ideas
as just like-
- As you get the freedom
to call or track "Noms".
(laughing)
- I guess the track name
doesn't really matter, right?
- When you're writing it,
like my process on this has
changed like a little bit
since "Shield Hero" admittedly
so I probably wouldn't do that again,
but it was-
- There was a process?
- You know, eventually.
Well, so when you're writing,
what I like to do is try
and match a lot of like
sort of the texture stuff I
was talking about earlier.
- Yeah.
- I love trying to match
texture to the actual visual
sort of palette, if you will.
Best way, like one of
the most sort of like
sort of basic examples or
classic examples I can give
is in "Made In Abyss" obviously like
it's quite a small amount
of like kind of characters
going to like huge like cavernous abyss
and started exploring.
And also you see in the visuals,
there's normally a lot of wide shots
where you just see kind of the-
- The scale.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It just goes like super far.
And so like the idea of
trying to actually depict
that visual sort of stimuli in music
is quite appealing to me.
It's sort of, yeah, almost like a,
it's called like word painting.
Which is basically like,
let's say you have lyrics and say,
"I am going to rise up",
and then the melody goes,
"I am going to rise up."
It's like literally rising with the-
- Like rising with the shield right.
- Rising with the shield.
- Well actually, 'cause in the main theme,
it's like the violin
start part of the start
does actually rise up.
- Right.
- And again, it's like,
it sounds so basic,
but it is good fun.
- Yeah.
- A lot of the like chord
stuff in "Made In Abyss"
more so like you saw that accession
so you hear a lot of like,
it's normally going down or up,
but like the whole idea of
like things rising and falling
as best as possible.
- So like, one thing I've
always wondered is pretty much
how you like blew up onto the scene.
'Cause I think like
you blew up immediately
in terms of like sound,
in terms of being a composer,
which is like, I find it's really rare,
but I think a big part of that was just
that opening scene in "Made In Abyss"
where it was just like the instrumental
with like the vocals as well,
and it was just no dialogue
it was just like a montage
just using this opening track.
And it just like immediately,
it not only did it sell you on the show,
but it just like put
your work onto the map.
Like how did that come about?
Was that planned or was that
just like a happy coincidence?
- I was like totally lucky.
And I'm glad I was like almost
'cause I had a different track.
I had had a much more subtle
track in mind for that.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Called "Swings And Roundabouts."
That was like kind of my
original idea for that theme.
So it was supposed to be,
oh, let's do these nice kind of
really cool textures and stuff
as the light kind comes over.
But then the sound
director and the director
decided differently to kind of,
'cause you don't write these,
unless it's a movie or
it's a specific scene
that's being requested to be written
synchronized to picture,
all the music is written
what's called free.
- Right.
- And then it's synced later.
- Oh.
So that wasn't meant to be synced at all?
- Originally like my like vision
of it was to be different,
but the director and the sound director
obviously had a pretty deep discussion,
they decided to put that song there
and even better they
decided to put it there
with minimal dialogue and sound effects
which is ridiculously like lucky.
And so just to, you know,
I guess just to like,
how do you even explain this?
To see that happen and
to be so happily wrong
about like what my vision was for that.
- Yeah.
- I think I was just like,
oh man, thank God people
are smarter than me.
But like, cause that song was written
just as sort of kind of
almost just like another,
like trying to make another
palette for the soundtrack.
Because when you start it
you just kind of going through like
point after point after point.
It's like, okay,
well let's just try and
write a piece of music
based off this manga panel,
or let's write a piece of music
based off this description
or this idea, you know,
obviously like reading
through the content and stuff.
- Oh right, so I was thinking like,
oh yeah, what do they give you?
I'm like, oh yeah, you
can just go to the manga
most of the time, right?
- Yeah.
Manga or in "Tower Of God"
you got manhwa as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That, it really is helpful.
- Yeah.
- Knowing the layout.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's super helpful.
And so just when you're able
to like kind of look at,
essentially you can just
see the entire story
kind of pan out.
Obviously you're given
like anime specific materials as well,
which is super, super helpful.
But yeah, when you're just
trying to find something
that actually kind of hopefully,
like what's the best word?
Respects the content as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, you're adding an audio element
that was not there before,
whereas the manga might be there before
so there might be reference,
you know, people might
be able to reference
the anime to the manga and say, okay,
well this is similar, this is different,
something like that.
The music never existed so.
It's both freeing and
also kind of terrifying
to, you know, potentially mess it up.
- Yeah, that's the thing.
'Cause like when I saw that scene,
I was like, this is so perfect
for this opening scene,
it must have been like specifically
made for this one scene.
- [Joey] Right.
- It was made around
like scenes like that.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah,
- Yeah, I would almost
describe it more as like,
it was almost an impression
of the show itself.
- Yeah.
Was that your first anime work?
- No, sir.
It was, geez that was my third.
- That was your third?
- Third, oh okay.
- Oh wow, okay.
- So no first one was,
it's all with the same
company Kinema Citrus,
but I did something called "Norn9".
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Can I ask, what is that?
- So "Norn9" is,
well actually it was a video game
and it was actually a video
game I did with Uematsu,
like way back when.
So he did the opening theme for that
and I did the BGM for
this game called "Norn9"
- Right, right, right.
- Then a couple years later
when I started doing anime
for this company called
Kinema Citrus they said,
"We're actually doing an
anime of "Norn9" as well."
- Right.
- And so I didn't-
- So you were like the natural pick?
- Yeah, maybe that was it.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Maybe that was it.
- 'Cause I mean, I guess, you know,
it makes sense to get the
guy who did the game, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So yeah.
- Yeah, shit.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I didn't think about that.
(laughing)
- Is that not obvious?
- No.
- As I sit here now in my fucking thirties
just fucking sipping sparkling water-
- You're like part of the coincidence.
(laughing)
- What happened is a coincidence.
- Like that wasn't like
a five head observation.
I was like.
- I'm a dumb bitch,
what do you want from me?
- Oh, okay wow.
- Okay, sorry, sorry.
I just apologized to a
microphone one, yeah.
- It's okay.
(laughing)
- This is exactly why
this thing is right here.
Another shock absorber.
- Absorbent.
Yeah, yeah.
So you did "Norn9"
- I was doing "Norn9" about the same time,
maybe this is why I didn't think about it.
I was also doing something
called "Under The Dog"
which was a-
- Yes, a kick starter.
- Oh.
- A kick starter, yeah,
that came first.
And so I didn't know like how
everything kind of progressed,
but I was on that for the trailer music
and then they asked if I wanted
to do the actual soundtrack.
- Yeah.
- So that was so cool.
Cause that was like the first one.
I was like-
- Oh wow, I had no idea.
- I was like, well, happy about that.
- Yeah.
- I've been like, you know, just fucking,
for lack of a better word,
fantasizing about fucking
trying to do anime for years.
I've been lucky enough to
do games for a couple years.
I'm like, Oh my God,
I'm so happy about that.
I was in college, I had just
finished college in London
so I was living here at the time.
Had no idea what was gonna
happen and all of a sudden boom,
like we were-
- Now you're in anime.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You were composing for
games while in college?
- Yeah, so when I was doing undergrad
that's when I started doing Uematsu stuff
and then that developed for another games,
both Japanese and-
- So you were busy in school?
- Yeah.
- I dunno how I did it
'cause again, maybe I'm-
- Maybe we'll get to the bottom of this
while talking to you.
- Yeah.
- You obviously don't track it.
- I'll make another five head observation.
- This is just like therapy times three.
Therapist times three.
It's like, oh my God,
everything makes sense,
it's all connecting, man.
It's it all connected dude.
(laughing)
But yeah, so I was working
throughout college as well
and yeah, it just happened.
I mean, I was just working
like work, work, work, work,
and just, you know-
- Just fell over and just happened.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Became a composer.
- [Kevin] Tripped and fell
into, yeah, the anime.
- Most people, me
included, don't do anything
while at college.
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay, I thought you
about say don't do anything-
- Like in general.
- I was about to say,
don't you dare go down that patch.
I'll bring out those
compliments straight away son.
- Okay, so like now what I
wanna know actually is like
how you and Garnt got to know each other.
'Cause like I kind of met
you guys through that, right?
Like I met you through Garnt and whatnot.
So like it's like where
was the connection there?
- That's a pretty simple connection,
I hope you remember it.
- But I have like a pre-story.
- Okay, okay.
- Which connects to that.
- Right, right.
- So I think I might have
like drunkenly mentioned this
to Sydney or something potentially,
but I don't think I've
mentioned it to any of you,
at least I don't remember mentioning it.
So I actually like,
when I was like going through
like college and stuff,
I like totally fell out of anime.
- Right, right.
- I was like, not watching it.
Like I remember I was
watching all the Ghibli stuff
and whatnot and some shows,
like some really important shows to me
to like kind of just to get
into anime kind of fandom
to begin with when I was like 14 or so
then I fell well out of it,
kind of went totally
underground for a long time.
And then what brought me back
was doing "Made In Abyss"
because I was like, you know,
it was like one of those
shows where like creatively
it was the first time I felt like,
oh, I'm actually doing music
that really feels like me sort of thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like I'm bringing
like a lot of the sort of
more experimental stuff
that I learned in, primary school,
in undergrad.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then like I did my masters in London
and that was sort of like honed
like film music craft a little bit.
- Right, right.
- What was your degree in, sorry?
- I did a Bachelor of
Composition of Music Technology
at the Western Australian
Academy of Performing Arts.
And then I did a Masters Of
Music Composition for Screen
at the Royal College Of Music in London.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh damn.
- No, no, we cool, we cool.
I can drop.
(laughing)
So yeah, I forgot I have a
fucking MA, that's hilarious.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- But no, I mean-
- We were going on WAAPA for so long,
he's like, oh yeah, I also have a masters.
- No, no, RCM was awesome.
I mean it really kind
of like honed the craft.
That's one of those like dub stuff,
and I just like learned how
to like produce music film.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah
- But WAAPA like focused a
lot more on experimental music
or new music,
a lot of art music a lot of-
- When you said WAAPA,
I thought you were
talking about the burger.
(laughing)
- I was on a binge just
eating a bunch of whoppers
experimenting with music.
(laughing)
- Sounds pretty accurate.
No, like this kind of all came
together for this project.
I mean, God bless Kinema Citrus, man,
they just gave me so much freedom,
like they gave me such like
kind of birth to just kind of
actually just kind of try some things
that I didn't know I could do it
and I felt really good
actually just kind of going
through that process of,
well, oh I remember like
that violin technique
I've never like tried before
and try that sort of thing,
and like, oh, I can try and like record
in this giant space in Vienna and that,
like can try and mimic
like the size of the abyss
sort of thing.
- Right, right.
- Trying those sort of techniques
that like were just introduced to me
either through undergrad or postgrad.
- [Garnt] Right.
- It was just really nice.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What was the question?
(laughing)
- How you and Garnt met?
- Oh, sorry.
There is a point to all this.
I promise there was a point.
Okay, so on the back of those feel goods,
you know, doing "Abyss."
- Yeah.
- I was curious, okay,
how is the show doing?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And I would type in, you know, the-
- You Googled yourself.
- You Googled yourself?
- No, no, no, I Googled "Made in Abyss".
I Googled "Abyss", I was like, okay,
how is it, you know, sort of thing.
And all these YouTuber guys
were starting to talk about it.
And I'm like, oh okay,
they're talking about it
and that they're liking it.
And then you made this video-
- Yeah.
- About like which music,
what was your favorite anime and what-
- I think it was like one
of my the anime of the year
kind of thing where I did like-
- Yeah, yeah.
Like, you know, you had
like the art category
and the animation category
and then you had the music category.
And you made this like great joke
like about the fact that I was Aussie.
- No 'cause,
there was this one clip that got posted
in like the behind the scenes documentary
of "Made In Abyss."
And of course it's like very
professionally made documentary
and there's just this one clip
of Kevin going to be like,
he was talking to someone
and I can't remember the exact line,
but he talks about,
he's like, you refer to
someone as like a mate
or something like that, right.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So Dmitri was the guy I was talking to.
He's like the main violinist
in all the "Abyss" stuff.
- Right.
- He is like the bosses of
bosses when it comes the violin.
He is unbelievable,
he has big deep voice, rumble.
So he's like, "Yeah, I'm
trying, it looks good."
Sorry, I don't do a
good impression of him.
(laughing)
- We don't know Dimitri,
so I don't even know.
- Yeah, I'm more just covering my arse.
(laughing)
'Cause I don't play violin, I play flute.
So I checked with college
friends before going over,
I'd be like, is this
shit, is this fucked up
if I give this to someone
in a recording studio?
'Cause obviously remember like
when you go into a recording session,
that's fucking thousands
of euros or dollars,
whatever it is, like a fucking hour.
Like we're talking like
five figures easily
in a couple of hours.
- Yeah.
- Like or eight hour
depending on how many
people you're hiring.
Super expensive scenario to be like,
oh the flute player wrote
fucking stupid fucking violin lines.
So checking with friends
or mates beforehand
was exactly what I did.
And I was trying to be chill about it
I was like, yeah, no, no,
I just checked with like a mate,
and like that, but the phrase mate
he did not understand,
he's Austrian American.
He was like, "Check with the what?"
I'm like, "With a friend."
(laughing)
- It was like in the behind the scenes?
- Yeah, it was in the behind the scenes.
- But you can't like fucking super impose
"The Land Down Under"
over that fucking clip.
Yeah, I mean I checked with a mate,
but he seemed to say that was okay.
- Checked with a what?
- With a friend.
- Okay.
- But for some reason it felt really cool
to have like that, you know,
that response from this
YouTuber fucking guy
and then I started getting
really curious about him.
Okay, this lovely gentleman over here
is thinking like this about,
you know "Made In Abyss."
Who else is thinking about,
like what does everyone else think about?
So like fucking AniTube
is where the reason
I got back into anime.
- Oh shit man.
- No shit.
- Holy shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- AniTube is doing a
positive thing to someone?
- I did something for
the anime industry, yo.
- You guys like brought me
back and then once "Abyss" hit,
we started going to conventions
and then I saw that you
were gonna be there.
I was like, oh I must say hello.
- Yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- I've been enjoying the
content and I have ever since.
- Yeah, 'cause like I remember
'cause we were both going
to Crunchyroll Expo,
and I was like, "Oh Kevin's going?"
And you know, when you like,
I don't know why, right,
you just like bring out
this aura of just like
he's a lad,
he's a fucking lad.
That was extrapolated just
from that one clip that's like,
"Oh, I checked with my mate."
And then he goes, "Check with the what?"
And you just see the panic being like,
"Check with the friend."
(laughing)
- It's equal parts resting
bitch face and spastic.
(laughing)
- And I was just like, from that one clip,
I was like, he seems like a lad.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Of course we met the first time
at like the bar or something.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
- Where more fitting.
- Yeah, where is a more fitting place
than meeting each other.
But I was-
- Are you Gigguk?
- Yeah.
And it was like, I was
like prepared to be like,
are you Kevin?
Oh my God I'm like a big fan of your work,
"Made In The Abyss"
was absolutely amazing.
Lo and behold, Kevin comes up to me
and taps me on the shoulder
and like at this time, you know,
AniTube was like way
smaller than it is now.
So like, I'm just like a random guy
who got just like invited
to this anime expo.
Been really excited to meet
people in the industry,
people who just actually worked on anime
and then Kevin taps me on
the shoulder and be like,
"Are you Gigguk?
"I fucking love your work."
I'm like, "Why are you saying this to me?
"I should be saying this to you."
- It's true.
No, that's the thing
I came from from the exact same position.
I was just like-
- Right, right.
- I was just happy to meet people.
I mean, because of that show, I'm here.
- Yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- We got to get together.
We and we, and it's like,
now it's like us.
- My first time meeting you
is when you ordered too much chicken
so that was a bonding experience.
- I was gonna say,
trauma is very good at bonding.
- I've never been back to that chain.
- Although the first time I met you
was at an iza kaya in Shibuya
and you were just like,
"Oh you wanna do a long high?"
(laughing)
And at first I was like, who's this bloke?
And then I realized this is fucking Kevin,
I was like, oh, okay.
- Like it takes four magna signs.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So of course like at Crunchyroll Expo
we like immediately bonded
over fucking getting pissed
as British and Aussies do.
- Of course.
- But like I remember you
got to a point of drunkness
where you started like spewing
some really interesting shit
about your creative
process of "Made In Abyss".
- I did that last to you.
- You did that last to me, yeah.
- Like, for some reason,
there's like a certain drunkness level
where Kevin gets really eloquent
about talking about his
creative process in music.
And he was talking about this one track
which was played over like
a very spoilerific moment
in "Made In Abyss" season one.
- Yeah.
- It was a very emotional moment
and he was talking about
like using like juxtaposition
and like techniques that you
learned from like university,
university and college.
And I remember being like,
I was pretty toasted I was just like,
this is really fucking interesting.
I just really like, as like an anime fan,
I would love to hear this when I'm sober
'cause I'm like not
remembering any of this.
So like I put a mental
note to ask him about it
the next day when I'm sober and so is he
so he can explain in more detail,
it was really fucking interesting.
So I go to Kevin and I was like,
"Kevin, you were talking about
this track in "Made In Abyss"
"and like how he came up with that
"and what process you did."
"Can you like expand on that
"cause that was really
fucking interesting?"
And he just looks at me and goes,
"I have no idea what
the fuck I said, mate."
(laughing)
- No, Kevin did that to me on Friday.
He went off about this one
synthesizer for like two hours.
He's like, "You don't understand,
"when you put your finger
on it it's like 50 springs,
"50 springs on your finger
"and it feels amazing."
- It is amazing.
- "It's like velvety
and it feels so good."
And I'm just like, uh huh, yeah.
- Imagine putting your finger on like,
you know, like divers, not skin.
- Like a wet suit.
- Yeah.
I got a synth that's
made out of diver wetsuit
with all these different
springs underneath
and you play it like a seaboard.
So like you play synths and stuff
but it's like legato sort of thing.
- Bold of you to assume I
know what a seaboard is.
- Oh yes, my bad.
So imagine a piano but with
no keys and it's just a line.
- Yeah, that's a seaboard, yeah.
- Like woo, like that.
Imagine doing that with a piano.
- Is that the thing that they did like
the fucking jerk it out meme on?
- What?
(laughing)
- No, no, no.
- What the fuck are you talking about?
(laughing)
- No you know it was
one of those (humming)
- No, no, no, not that,
not that, not that.
It's like, imagine that
but instead of a pen,
it's your finger.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- This is a pen.
- Called a pen this.
So he was going off about that
for like what felt like two hours.
And it was really interesting,
but I was the exact same situation.
I was like, I'm really hammered,
this is really cool.
You're showing me all
these like YouTube videos
in this like really loud bar
and I'm like having to do this.
- Yeah, it's like really
like specific kind of like,
like nuanced sound.
- Yeah.
- Like I was like, oh,
it's a 43 minute video,
just let me scrub for a minute.
(laughing)
Yeah.
- It's like great when
you're hearing someone
who's like so passionate about something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, to be fair, like I
do actually fucking love it.
Like I might like joke
about it a little bit
and oh, I don't remember
how this fucking happened.
- But you know, it's like
at least like, you know,
as like a fellow musician,
I understood majority
of what you were saying.
I can't imagine what
it was like for Garnt.
It's just like hearing all
these like musicology terms
and just like being like, yeah.
- Have you ever heard a moose?
Something like that.
- Garnt's like.
- Is that something I should know?
- I don't know why I chose a moose.
- I asked about like the "Doom" soundtrack
and you were telling me
about how to compose it,
he got some Russian synth and I was like-
- You were telling me.
- I was like, I understand
that it being from Russia
could add to the sound of
it sounding more doom like.
Yeah, I was just like,
I'm in my head I'm like,
does the Russia have a lot
of influence on the synth
being like more dooms esque?
Like is the soundtrack of
Russia just doom, like?
- I feel like I like once I tired you out,
I like went next victim.
We were like, so let me tell
you about Russian synthesizers.
- Yeah, I was like, I
dunno any synthesizer,
but I'm open to hear.
- Yeah, so the polyvox is
a Soviet era synthesizer,
it's about 50 kilograms
and it has like the one of
those gnarly fucking sounds.
Okay, synthesizer is based,
I mean, among other things,
it's voltage being put
through an oscillator.
- Okay.
- Right.
- So it's a fucking biblical sound.
It is beautiful.
And the way that you can
shape these oscillators
and then filter them through
different effects and stuff
makes a synthesizers character come out.
So like the different types
of processing that you have,
I mean, you can just
listen to the oscillator
be an oscillator.
But at the same time,
the way that it's processed
through certain other
like kind of effects and
boards in a synthesizer
gives it a certain unique character.
- This is exactly how we
sounded that night by the way.
- I'm sober.
- Very elegant.
- But like, you know, in the same way,
like you have like a guitar, right
and you have different makes of a guitar,
depending on how it's made,
the pickups and stuff like that,
it'll have a different characteristic.
Think of it like that, but electricity.
- Okay.
- Right, right.
- And so this particular synthesizer
that yeah, was used in
the "Doom" soundtrack.
I would love to get one, but like
they're not easy to get on my own,
it's like they are dated instruments now,
that is a dated instrument.
- So is your house just filled with
just instruments and synthesizers
and a whole bunch of other random stuff?
- Yeah, so my fucking,
I guess call it both a quarter life crisis
and like my pandemic kind of like-
- Pandemic crisis.
- Right, right.
- Depression fucking fuck
COVID sort of like outlet
was just to fill this room
with just all this fucking
shit to just record.
And like it helped a lot.
- Yeah.
I mean, I saw you tweeting
about it constantly, right.
So I'm like, yeah, it was all,
but like that's the problem is that like,
all it took was for me
to ask about this like
one particular synthesizer
that I really liked.
All I said was, "So Kevin,
I heard you bought a Moog."
And then he just went off for two hours.
- It's like, let me
tell you my life story.
- Yeah.
- Now we always think like,
what's the opposite of,
you know the "Horse Girl",
well, apparently it's the Synthesizer Guy.
- It's the Synthesizer Guy.
(laughing)
The Synth Guy.
- I'm still trying to figure out
why I tried to make you think about
what a moose sounds like.
I don't know why I picked that.
See, this is a problem,
it's like I'm too sober.
It's funny.
- I'm not making enough sense.
- Yeah, I'm not making enough sense, yeah.
It's like a little gray area
where between like
dysfunctional and functional,
functional, dysfunctional.
Again, why would I just decide?
- Yeah, I know everything
upside, down is up.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- So I'm a bit afraid to ask
after what we've just talked about,
but what is your creative process?
Do you have one?
- Right.
(laughing)
- 'Cause I'm sure you have
like the answer prepared
for like, when you get
asked that on a panel
and like, I hear you answer
that question on a panel
and I'm just like that,
that is not like the Kevin I know.
- So yeah.
So it's kind of weird cause
I don't like, I haven't-
(laughing)
- He's buffering, he's buffering.
- What is it like the
old DLR whatever, DSR
whatever it's called, a DLR (mumbles)
My bad.
This is it, this is the process right now.
- This is the process.
- Fucking having some
fucking stroke on camera.
(laughing)
- Is it's all good, it's all good.
- How much usable content
will actually make it.
- It's all cut.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- It's a one minute super cut video.
- Yeah.
- He left, the end.
- Is it the beeps and the boops?
- No, well yeah.
So it comes from like,
it comes from many places.
- Right.
- I can't make that sound good
so I'm just gonna meme it.
But so let's say for example,
one way is that I've like woken up
in the middle of the night,
I had like some sort of
fucking weird fever dream,
but then I've woken up with
like some sort of melody
in my head.
- Yeah.
- I'll write it down
as like almost like a musical
morse code on like Evernote,
'cause I got like Evernote
and I love using it.
I'll do like a little memo it's like,
B, dash, dash,
is like B for two beats.
So I'll write like a
tempo and maybe like a-
- You wake up thinking about melodies?
- Only like sometimes,
but then the problem is I'll
like write it down and be like,
oh, man this is fucking good,
I'm gonna go back to sleep now
I'm gonna wake up nice early
after I've had a nice rest
and you know, just like get to work.
And I wake up and like,
oh, it's fucking nothing for me.
- So I have to like
reinterpret what I like wrote.
- Memento but with music.
- Cause I used to do that as well.
But now when I do it-
- Yeah.
- I just sing into my phone.
So the next morning I
wake up and I'm just like,
it's just like audio of
me just like (humming),
just like really quietly
like three in the morning.
Archie must think I'm fucking psychotic.
'Cause just singing to myself
at three in the morning.
But it helps.
- I mean, another way that I'd
like start a piece of music
would be like, let's you just
try and like find a cool sound
or a cool like-
- Right, right, right, right.
- So yeah, whether it be like
one of the therapy synthesizers
that I decided to buy.
- Which synthesizers
should I use to today?
- Just loading up Logic
Pro and just being like,
okay, let's fuck around
and just see what happens.
Just do a little cheeky little
piano sometimes it's nice.
- Start playing stuff?
- Yeah. It's just like,
well most of it's shit,
but then eventually you
get something that's like,
okay, it's not too shit
that I couldn't come back
and like refine it later.
- Right.
- There might be a little
bit of a riff sometimes,
stuff like that.
But so like,
let's take "The Rising Of The
Shield Hero" the main theme.
At the start it's just
like sad piano, (humming)
It's like sad piano.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But then you have this violin
coming in and going (humming).
- Yeah, yeah.
- It kind of, it rises up.
- Yeah.
(humming)
(laughing)
- It's the Mario theme.
- I was like, I don't remember that
in "The Rising Of The Shield Hero."
- No, I would be very out
of work if I did that.
- The Nintendo lawyer is
knocking at your door.
- I was trying to do like the (humming)
What's the melody version of that?
I guess that, but it's really not.
I'm sorry people.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry guys I'm sober.
- Yeah.
- I'm too sober for this.
- I didn't come prepared.
Like my blood alcohol is not of par?
So "The Rising Of The Shield Hero" piece.
So the (humming) kind of starts.
So I would start with that
and try and work around that.
I guess you could think
of it as like, you know,
you creating like one little line
and then you're creating
another little line
that kind of connects to that.
And so it kind of just
slowly becomes like a
sort of a bit more of a
complicated kind of beast.
- Cause like patchwork
type of thing, right?
- And then like you kinda
like go back to like kind of
fill in and refine.
- Damn.
- Right.
- So like maybe I'll have
like a structure of something,
I'll have like, you know,
most of a structure of
something to work with,
and then I'll just kind
of sit back and be like,
okay, what sucks?
What needs to be changed?
And just kind of refine.
It's almost like, is it drench fishing?
- What's that?
- It's where like they-
- Oh you just throw the net out.
- Yeah, where it's like a net
and they just gotta drag the sea bed
and so like pick up fish like that way.
It's like a filter process where you drag-
- Dredging.
- That was the loudest like
five seconds of silence
ever on the show.
- That was like the loudest silence
I've ever heard in my life.
- I was trying to process.
- It was like.
- I think, yeah, I was
trying to say dredge,
but then I thought of
like the Mariana Trench
and then I combined.
Welcome to the fucking
frightening nightmare
that is my head.
- Drench fishing.
- Yeah, dredge fishing.
But like you think of that as like,
but you're just like going through,
you listening, you listening,
I dunno what this action is anymore.
And then you're just kind of
refining, refining, refining
until you kind of can't find any more
like flaws so to speak-
- Right, right, right.
- For you to try to fix.
Or you run outta time, but yeah.
- Do you kinda like show
those like unfinished
or like, you know, combed through pieces
to like other people to
get like a second opinion?
Or do you kind of just like-
- All the time, all the time.
There's like a few kind
of like core people
where I'll be like, Hey, so just you know-
- Right, just be honest.
- Yeah.
- Just tell me real.
- What's the track and you wrote like,
and you just like this one's the banger,
this one's a fucking banger
and I can't wait to hear this.
- This is the one that
will explode my career.
- No, I don't think like that.
I don't think like that.
- Okay.
- What I normally like more,
what I gravitate more
in terms of like being
confident about a track
is kind of the process of it.
- Yeah.
- I use an example that
I can't tell you like now
about like last night,
but like let's take like "Made In Abyss"
season one, for example.
- Right.
- There's a track that I mentioned earlier
called "Swings and Roundabouts"
and it involves a really cool sort of
arpeggio style playing technique
with arpeggiation on a violin.
So normally when you play a violin,
and I'm sorry, any violinists
out there about to hate me
because I'm gonna explain
what a violin does
like as a flautist and it's gonna suck.
But if you think of it,
'cause normally you see a violin
they play one or two strings at the time
and then they normally like
change their fingers like that.
One of the techniques
that I really enjoyed
was where they put fingers
in all four strings
and then just kind of bow up and down
on all four strings and
almost make like a chord.
So well, if you do like
that, doesn't do much,
but you go one, two, three, four,
back one, two, three, four.
(humming)
So it's like this kind of cool
kind of chord sort of thing
and you can play it very, very fast
'cause they're fucking good musicians.
But then you can change that all the time.
So you're almost like, (humming)
and kinda changing chords all the time
and you can make like
these really cool, like,
'cause it's very shimmery sort of texture.
But I did that on one violin.
In "Abyss" season one we had
three violins, three viola,
two celli, and one bass,
and they were all of them
playing like solo parts.
So it's like nine solos together.
- Right, right, right.
- And they're all playing
these different chords,
like arpeggiated chords together
and it's sort of making this bit of this
sort of cacophony of
like sounds and stuff.
So like doing those sorts of things
makes me feel good about that track.
It's like, oh, I got to explore
this kind of crazy thing,
or I got to-
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's like, oh, I got to
like kind of explore that
and it didn't fucking fail.
- And it sounds good.
- Yeah.
- It sounds great, yeah.
And I like the noise.
- Yeah, this is so alien to me.
You're explaining all this stuff
and it literally just
sounds like another world.
Like, it doesn't sound like a thing
that I can even comprehend,
but I appreciate it 'cause you know,
I know you are making sense.
It's just like,
to me I have such
engineering and math brain.
The way I approach everything and like,
it's very like, okay, I just do what I do,
there's nothing that's
like just a gut feeling.
- There's no experimentation.
- Yeah.
- You know, there's-
- But I mean, there needs
to be a part of that
in this process.
- Right.
- 'Cause experience means that
you can execute these ideas.
- True, true, true.
- I've had like crazy fucking
ideas I have no idea how to do
and I still don't.
- Yeah, I was gonna ask,
when you said to me earlier,
so like you mentioned that you're in like
a chapel or something and you're recording
like an orchestra or something.
- [Kevin] Right.
- How do you go like,
Hey, higher ups, I have this idea,
I'd like to rent out a
church somewhere in Austria.
Could we ship and get
a bunch of violinists
and all the people there?
And yeah, it might work out.
Let's just see how it goes.
By the way it's a hundred
thousand dollars for two hours.
- The might part is
definitely not something
that I translate.
- Yeah.
- You're like it's definitely gonna be.
- It's definitely gonna work.
- Like first off, thankfully
there's trust so like that.
- [Connor] Right, you've proven that you-
- Yeah, a little bit of trust.
But so obviously like
when you start a project,
you're given a budget.
And you know, the budget, you know,
sometimes you can like kind
of stretch a little bit
and you know, you can do some
little bit of black magic just
to get some deals and stuff.
- Is budget like, this might sound stupid.
There's a budget and then you
get your pay separate, right?
That's like completely
or is it like you have to decide?
Make it all in one.
- No, there's a composer's
fee and then there's a budget.
- [Connor] Right, right okay makes sense.
- Production fee is pretty standard.
But so when we were able to
kind of like explore this idea
of using "Made In Abyss" as an example,
like yeah, we were trying to explore
like this massive studio
called The Synchron Stage in Vienna,
which I think it fits like 135 musicians.
It's a massive room.
Like I'm pretty sure it's
like a football field
if not slightly more like it is big.
- I understand that metric.
- Yeah.
- A football, oh no there we go.
- And like it is got a
really unique sound profile.
And so you can stick like
a really small amount
of musicians in there
and it will sound fucking huge.
'Cause they've put all
these microphones around.
So you get all these ambient microphones,
they stick them up like 30
feet up in the air and stuff
and you have, they're called out triggers,
and you got like everything, man,
you got all this sound to play with.
- Is that not just like a nightmare
to go through all those different like
angles of sound?
- Nah, it's a pleasure mate.
Absolutely.
- To me you're saying
that to me and I'm like,
holy shit the shut up required.
- Kevin gets off on that.
- I'm raging hard on from that.
(laughing)
- Just setting up like four
mics for this fucking podcast
gives me aneurysm.
- He sees a mic 30 feet up in the air
he's just bricked on,
he's like damn, that's
gonna sound so good.
These mic's got me acting up.
(laughing)
- You have absolute permission
to like slit my throat
if I don't actually
utilize a space like that.
Like you'd be fucking nuts dude.
But no, like so space is phenomenal
and then we get a small
amount of musicians.
We decided like, okay,
small amount of characters in the show,
small amount of musicians
to kind of like mimic that,
that kind make that party size.
- Yeah.
- And so just having like, yeah,
like three solo violins,
three solo violas,
two solo cello, one solo bass,
but then them all kind
of doing their own thing,
but because the space
is so good and so clean,
you can have all these voices like really,
if you orchestrate correctly.
- Right.
So it's like if you balance
your textures correctly
and all that sort of shit.
- Yeah.
- You can have like a really rich sound
with a small amount of people
and it can sound phenomenal.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- It's beautiful.
It's really fun.
- You're performing magic.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You've just said like so
many words that I'm like,
oh damn.
- Damn man, say that again.
- Cause sometimes like-
- I appreciate it.
- Not at all, but I mean sometimes like
just the basic stuff,
like even just doing the bass,
but it is like kind of,
let's call it simple,
like refined simple sort of ideas
is really, really fun.
One of the other tracks
that's in Abyss season one
called "Recapitulation".
- [Garnt] What's that?
- Something recapitulation, sorry.
I should probably remember my own tracks.
(laughing)
But it just involves the nine strings
like playing just notes (humming)
and all they're doing
is changing the duration of the bow hand
in order to get shorter
or longer notes. (humming)
So they have like three different
levels of length of note.
- But it's the same note?
- Right, it's the same note.
I mean we change up the chord sometimes,
but it is quite minimalistic
in that particular track.
But so basically if you change
the texture in that room,
because you have something called,
oh Christ I should probably
remember the damn thing.
(laughing)
The, what's it called?
Nope.
- No, all right.
You'll remembering it, you'll remember it.
- All good man, all good.
- It's like early reflections,
early reflections.
I think it's called early reflections.
- Okay.
- Right, right, right.
- The early reflections of the sound.
So like the sound that kind of like,
'cause sound's flying
everywhere in the room.
- Right, it's the one
thing i do understand.
- Sound goes everywhere
and obviously it bounces
off certain points
and then comes back to the microphone.
Those early reflections,
early reflections in that
room are really, really cool.
And they have a lot of character
'cause it's almost like an echo effect
or like a chorus effect.
And so for example, if I
recorded your voice in there,
but I didn't use like the
mic that's in front of you,
but I used the mics that caught like
the first reflections
of you just behind you
or in front of you or something like that,
it would almost sound like
there's like 10 of you.
- Right, right.
- It has a really cool chorus effect.
It's quite unique to that.
- 'Cause it's kinda like spread out
and bounced around a little bit, yeah.
- Just cause of the quality of the wood
in the room and stuff
like that, things change.
And so it is like a really good room.
- So is this place like famous?
Because I can't imagine,
okay, you're gonna record a soundtrack.
You want like a certain sound profile
for like "Made In Abyss"
cause this place seems
like it was tailor made
for a series like "Made In Abyss"
set in caverns and wide open spaces.
How would you like go about finding
the perfect recording spot
or the perfect recording space?
- It was the correct recording spot, yeah.
- Yeah, the correct.
- For Abyss it was that one.
Well 'cause for "Rising
Of The shield Hero"
we recorded in Boston
with the rock orchestra,
and they specified in rock orchestra.
So the players did live
performances at the time
with a full live band.
I think they did some
"Final Fantasy" stuff
among other Square Enix projects,
among other things as well.
So they like kind of specialized
in that kind of quite cool
kind of attitude orchestra with rock,
which is what we wanted to achieve here.
"Tower of God",
obviously, I mean it
is in the name as well.
It has like a slightly biblical
sort of sensibility about it.
And we found this hall
in the Czech Republic
called the Dvorak Hall.
So it's this beautiful old hall.
It was built I think
in the name of Dvorak.
So he's like a very,
very, very famous composer
of romantic,
late romantic music I should say.
But so this hall was designed
either for him or by him or around him.
So sorry about not
being specific about it,
but it is a beautiful concert hall.
It is ancient, it has this beautiful lush
sort of like reverb tower and stuff.
It is pretty to like listen to.
And it's a performance hall
but they also do recording there.
And so we recorded string
orchestra there for "Tower of God"
because it had this sort
of almost cathedral esque
sort of sensibility about it
which worked great for certain aspects
of the "Tower Of God"
soundtrack in terms of concepts.
- Right, right, right.
- So this one hall,
they had a very specific sound that say
a normal cathedral wouldn't?
- I'm sure a normal cathedral would,
but that's when
practicality comes into it.
So I make sure at the end
of the day that, you know,
again, you gotta fit
within certain budgets
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, that's part of like
the business skills part
of it which come in.
- Right, right, right.
- 'Cause I imagine you
have these grandiose ideas
and this concept that you have,
and there's a guy there that is like,
"I am here to scale you back down."
(laughing)
- Sir you're pushing the envelope
a little bit, aren't you?
- Just like, I wanna record on the moon.
Cause it's a space opera.
(laughing)
So I'm like, you know, yeah.
- You know that there's
no sound the space?
(laughing)
- We're getting real experimental,
we're gonna build a cathedral in space.
- Yeah.
Apparently a dying black hole,
or like a black hole is
like the loudest sound ever,
but you can't hear it.
- I believe that.
- Yeah probably, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
The moon would be nice,
but I don't think I'm gonna.
(laughing)
- You're not gonna make a
whole lot of progress there.
- No, no.
- Tell us the fact about
the dying black hole
being the loudest thing.
- I think they did manage to record it.
Oh no, yeah I think it
must be the loudest sound
'cause it's it's a black
hole consuming stars.
But they managed to record the sound of it
I think recently.
And it's like just this
eerie fucking, yeah,
it's atoms being crushed into nothing.
- Yeah, right, right, right.
- Anyway, yeah.
- Interesting bit for the tea.
- You're not going to the moon,
you're not going to the moon.
(laughing)
- Second loudest is a
"Modern Warfare 2" lobby.
- Exactly, exactly.
- So like going like, I guess
moving from "Made In Abyss",
one thing I've noticed is that
you always try to do something new
with like every new
project that you take on,
I guess that's why you put
a lot of experimental stuff
into "Made In Abyss."
And I feel like "Tower Of God", right,
that's just like dubstep,
which is like so far removed
from what you were
doing in "Made In Abyss.
Like how did that come about?
- Like did you have to listen
to like a lot of dubstep
to like study it?
Or did that just like come.
- Did they tell you or was
that your decision to be like,
I'm gonna put a bunch of fucking
dubstep in there right now.
- No, it's 'cause I used to
go to a lot of fucking raves.
(laughing)
- I just feel like being at a rave.
- No, no.
Like one of the people I worked with that,
okay pre-story again, but like, yeah.
So Perth has like a
massive drum bass scene.
- Really in the back story.
- Yeah. Yeah.
But well Pendulum are
from there for example.
- Oh yeah true.
- Of course, of course.
- Like it has a great scene and yeah.
So when I went to WAAPA,
I got introduced, 'cause I was like,
oh, I love video game music
and that's it sort of thing.
But then one of my friends,
one of my really, really
close, best friends
that I still, you know,
we're still really, really close today.
So we've known each other for,
fuck it's getting on 13 years now.
But yeah, he used to be like,
"Oh, well we're going to
this fucking, you know,
"like hotel bar to go to
rave and I've got a track
"and one of the DJs is playing
one of my drum bass tracks.
"Come."
And then yeah, just do
a bunch of fucking like
vodka cruises and whatnot,
just dance, like a fucking energizer bunny
on the fucking floor
for like three or four hours
and it would be great.
And so I kind of kept that,
and when I moved here,
obviously, you know,
this big kind of EDM, yeah.
- I'd just like to imagine you
at like Defqon or something
and you're just standing there like,
they don't know I'm a flautist.
(laughing)
He's just like standing there.
- I'm very good at the
world's shittiest shuffle,
you know, like.
(laughing)
- I would pay to see that.
- Yeah, no.
But that culture of dance
music and especially-
- Like hardcore music.
- Yeah, well either liquid
drum bass or dark drum bass
so I can just kept with me.
So like, if you think about
like kind of those elements
where it's either like very,
very fluid sort of synthesizers
or it can be like,
like there are some fucking
hardcore like music,
like in that genre.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If you've like been to like a,
ah man, there's so many like examples,
but you know, if you hear like a,
oh I can't even think of like.
I remember going to a couple of gigs
in either south or east
London when I was living here.
And the fucking bass
that comes out some of
these like venues, man.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh yeah.
- Cause there's like speakers like.
I went to this warehouse gig once,
I can't remember where
'cause it's been so long ago.
But like I remember like just
walls and walls of speakers
for hundreds of meters.
And then because it's like
a three story warehouse,
so they've got speakers going up.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fucking bass that
comes out of those mixes
when you are on the dance floor, you know,
obviously you had a couple
of your vodkas tonics
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Man, you just like it's wetting.
- You feel every atom
in your body just like-
- Shake.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Especially the bass,
like it's a fucking physical reaction,
it's fucking biblical man, it's so good.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so like-
- You know the bass is good
when you don't hear it, you just feel it.
- You do feel it.
- That's such a good adjective, biblical.
I'm gonna use that more often.
- It's resonating in your chest cavity.
It's really good.
And it feels awesome,
and it sounds great as well
until your ears start bleeding.
- Is this chicken sandwich biblical?
(laughing)
- Fucking biblical mate.
- It's so good that Jesus
had to get involved.
(laughing)
- It is a little spiritual I would say.
There's a little spiritual.
But yeah, so that
culture and that feeling-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Still is with me,
even though I write a lot of
more orchestral music as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So when it came to "Tower Of God",
if you look at the manhwa,
because manhwa, unlike
manga, is colorized.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So if you look at the color palette
for "Tower Of God" in the manhwa,
it's actually very minimalist.
You normally like three or four
like very big bold colors on a panel.
And then you go back
and so you see these really interesting,
like some of the characters
are sometimes just silhouettes
against like a huge, beautiful background.
In front of a giant creature
or something like that.
So as a composer,
it's like kind of a bit of a wet dream,
it's really good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So if you think about
taking really bold colors
that are contrasting
and trying to put them
together in a musical sense.
- Yeah.
- Like you can split into,
let's say a frequency range.
You can go high, mid, low.
- Yeah.
- I did a theme for one of
the characters called Rachel.
And her theme is literally just harp.
So it's harp in the middle,
there's like dial up style tones on top,
and then just this bass comes in
to just kind of punch you
in the face, essentially,
the chest cavity.
And so like that sort of like dub step
with harp for example, like, you know,
how can we find interesting combinations
that still kind of relate
back to this idea of
frequency spectrums being kind of split up
to represent very minimalist,
but maximalist style
coloring in the panels.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That sort of thing.
- So like, you know,
you have these kind of pretty harp
then all of a sudden (growling)
- Yeah.
- You know, and then like
also like very subtle,
I know, welcome.
But like, you know,
these sorts of like also radical
changes in texture as well,
like that suits "Tower Of
God" in my mind at least.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, it definitely did.
- So like when you handed it to them
and you're like, "Here it is."
Were they like, "whoa."
- Well it was kind of interesting
'cause we did essentially
what you could call
almost like a concept album.
We did like 13 tracks.
We were like,
we're gonna put together
13 contrasting tracks to-
- That's quite a lot of tracks.
- A lot of it was a big investment.
But like we did like the first 13 tracks
as like sort of proof
the concept saying like,
this is what we wanna do,
this is how we wanna do it.
We gonna do this style
of choir and you know,
this harp and dub step by idea
and want to, you know,
punch people in the face
with like beats and shit.
And they were all for it.
Which again, just fucking lucky,
and thank you to them
for like actually just being like-
- Being cool with it.
- Yeah, we're cool
- We feel like when you
explain stuff for music,
I'm like, yeah, okay all right.
- I have achieved the impossible.
(laughing)
- If I was the exec I'd be like,
you sound like you know what you're doing.
(laughing)
I'll just believe you.
- You mentioned the word biblical,
that's all I need to know.
- You said biblical, minimalist,
and then maximalist
within like one second.
And I was like, that sounds
like you know what's up.
- It's like look into my eyes.
(laughing)
- Just like, I'm trying
to, I'm like, yeah okay.
Harps go with it,
yeah, of course harps go bass.
- Yeah, of course.
- Well, at the end of you
also need to, you know,
execute the concept.
- Of course, yeah, yeah.
- And so like, you know,
cause obviously everything's done
kind of in a computer so to speak
until you go to the recording process.
You are also showing a demo,
you're not showing like the
full release sort of thing.
So then you've gotta
potentially risk, you know,
going and finding the right musician,
finding the right space,
within the right budget of course as well.
- Are you the one handling
all of this or is the?
- Oh I mean,
I've got sort of the music
supervisor, the director.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That we work with every day so.
- So if you need someone
to play the harp, right,
you need someone to record it.
You're like, I know a guy,
or you're like, please
find me a harp person.
- Well, this is the lucky part
about going to a music college.
- Cause you know everyone.
- You get to know bunch of musicians.
- So a couple of the composer friends
that I went to WAAPA with and,
sorry I'm gonna come back to it,
but like, you know,
it's all connected, man.
All connected.
(laughing)
- My man's got Dimitri on speed dial.
He's like ay yo,
I know the guy.
- What we say most of the
times is just happy birthday.
- He knows a mate.
- Yeah, he knows a mate.
- Yeah, he's a beautiful boy,
a beautiful man I should say.
So like for example like
when I went to undergrad in WAAPA,
like I had a couple of friends and stuff
that like I started working
with on "Tower Of God".
So, you know, Matt Mclean,
Feeding Ear is his name
and we did some drum bass
stuff for "Tower Of God"
and that was like really, really nice.
And then I knew some
musicians cause I went to,
yeah, The RCM here in London
and like those student
musicians are bloody good.
- Yeah.
- Student musicians of
the RCM become, you know,
they have a very, very good chance
of becoming working musicians.
- You'd hope so, you'd hope so.
- They are beautiful musicians
and because you just
basically breaking bread
with these guys for
two, three, four years.
I mean you are going to the RCM bar
and you're getting hammered
with these guys all the time.
And so, you know, you
have like this connection
'cause you know, in the
same way that we kind of,
you know, broke a little bread
over about 600 gin tonics, you know,
you do the same with like
the musicians and stuff.
They're good friends,
but they also they just come to work.
- Sounds like every aspect
of the entertainment industry
it's like you can be good at what you do,
but also you need to go
out and talk to people.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Exactly.
- It's super important.
And so when it came to
certain projects like this,
like "Tower of God".
I mean Valeria was the harp player
and she does not only classical harp,
but she also does improv harp.
So I could just give her like, you know,
I could almost give him some, you know,
really piece of shit
fucking like sheet music
where I was like, I've done
my best to like make it so
that it doesn't look
like an absolute insult,
but feel free to like just interpret this
in a non shitty way.
- Right, right.
- I was gonna ask you about this.
So it's like, you're
mentioning that you are the one
writing the sheet music roughly.
How do you come across the knowledge
of every single instrument
you want to use?
- [Kevin] Pain and
suffering, and practice.
- Because it's like, cause
obviously if you're a violinist,
you do violin and you are very good at it.
But like, you are like, I need
to know this Russian synth.
Also can I find the harp
and I need to write that.
Like this sounds like
an overload of knowledge
that you have to acquire,
or have a rough understanding
of almost everything.
- So yeah.
So when you are orchestrating
for a large one,
so harp is a very, very specific
and very unique instrument
and it works on a pedaling system
which I understand the concept of
but I don't know how to like achieve.
So what I would say is that
you kind of working up your base knowledge
of certain things.
- Right.
- Obviously like when I write
like woodwind sectionals,
it's a lot kind of,
let's call it more natural for me.
- 'Cause you understand that.
- Yeah, it's like, okay, I understand that
if I do something quite fucky
that there's gonna be a will or a way
to kind of get it done.
That's why you'll hear like
quite a few flute passages and whatever
and you hear a lot of flute
jumping up and down and up
and down and up and down
because like, ah yep.
- It's just your comfort
instrument, right?
- Yeah.
- It's just like,
- But then when it comes to
say Dimitri, the violinist,
because he is such a fucking boss,
I can do like what would normally be
insultingly stupid shit,
but he'd be like, "Okay, let's go."
And just fucking.
"I can do this, I can do that."
And then just fucking like
does all these different
permutations of it.
Just do a bunch of takes
and just cut them together
and it just sounds fucking awesome.
And I just sat there like,
oh shit, it actually worked.
And then like, so it is literally like
fuckload trial and error.
- I was gonna it must, it
must be a long journey.
- Couple of risks, but then also yeah,
like I did learn orchestration.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is basically just going through,
yes, going through every
instrument and just being like,
what does and does not work
and you just build it up.
So flute,
but then there's alto flute, base flute.
And then yeah, base flute
has certain characteristics
in which, you know, if you
go too high on the base flute
it's gonna start doing overtones
which the alto flute and the
flute or the piccolo won't do
in the same way.
- Would you say there's
always a concern then
when you're like,
I don't want this guy to
think I'm a fucking idiot
for writing this
and then handing it to a professional.
- That's why I like getting
a chilled atmosphere
in the studio.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- For example, that's why
if you've seen in that-
- That's when he start
to call people mates.
(laughing)
- Yeah, it's like, you
wanna bring your A game.
So you come with like
the best possible job
that you could have done.
- Yeah.
- You've done as much research as possible
on the instrument.
- I'd be shitting myself.
- Yeah.
I mean, 'cause that's why
I gained a lot of weight
in the pandemic.
So I'm just working,
but I couldn't do anything
like kind of get rid of
the stress cause it's like,
okay, I need to do this,
I need to do that.
And like the "Star Wars" scene
like you know, you wanna
make sure that is right.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- You wanna bring the
best fucking sheet music.
You want it to be beautifully type set.
You want that to be the best looking music
you've ever written.
- Right, right, right.
- On page and you want
the musicians to be happy
because you want the project to go
really, really well please
and thankfully it did,
but like again like,
you bring your A game
and then you give the
musician enough adequate scope
if there is a mistake.
- Yeah.
- You know what it is,
it's almost like you're refining
the level of potential mistake
down to where there's like,
you're in a sphere of like safety.
And then within that,
if there's a mistake,
if there's something like that.
Oh, that dynamic doesn't work,
that doesn't work, that doesn't work.
Blah, blah, blah.
- Will they tell you?
They'll be like, "Yeah, this
part isn't really doable."
Or like, let's just try it.
- They should tell you,
and that's why it's good to be like,
Hey, just so you know,
if there is anything wrong, just tell me,
I don't mind.
- Yeah.
- That's why I guess, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- But that is literally the conversation,
you have that conversation all the time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause you like, yeah,
there are people that,
you know, where it's like,
"Okay, we'll go for a take now.
"Okay, thank you."
- Yeah.
- There are people like
that and like that's fine.
But I guess maybe like my style
right now at least is like,
I'm just happy to be here,
you know, I wanna make this-
- I'm just a mate.
- I'm just mate.
- I haven't composed anything yet,
but they keep rehiring me.
- Just tell me if I'm being a dickhead.
Just tell me.
- Like, just, we're gonna sit down,
we're just gonna play it through,
if there's any questions,
you know, I've done my best,
make sure that you guys have a good time.
And if you do a good time,
I feel like you just,
'cause I was explaining this
to you last night as well.
Like there's a couple
of thoughts of school
about like how many takes you should do.
And you know, in certain
countries they'll be like,
one, two or three or four takes
that you'll do a run through
and then they'll be
like, "Okay, we're done."
- Right.
- And then there's other times
where there were these
other types of composers
where you'll basically like
do like multiple takes,
even like what would be considered
potentially unnecessary takes,
just to get like different
kinda like permutations
and certain phrases like that.
So you can cut together
and kind of do like kind
of different things.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'm in that second part.
- I was gonna say.
- Right, right it did seem like you are.
- Which is really not economical,
but at the same time,
there's been countless times
where I've been able to basically like
create a really cool sort
of almost like a combination
or like an amalgamation,
what am I trying to say?
- Yeah amalgamation, yeah.
- Of like different takes
where like, you know,
I was like, oh, like bar 34, beat four,
the cello like kind of
slipped a little bit
on that one note and it
sounds a little fucked up,
but let's cut that in 'cause
I like the fucked upness,
and then go back to like this other take,
which is a bit more clean,
something like that.
And then let's bring
in this sort of thing.
- The more you're telling me about it,
the more stressed out I'm getting,
like what if you know,
if you have, like you said,
you had a three of each
instrument earlier.
- [Kevin] Yeah, yeah.
- What if like one guy's
just sick, doesn't turn up?
Or like-
- That's not a thing.
- Not a thing?
- No, it shouldn't be.
(laughing)
- What if like someone's
they gotta fly over
their visa gets delayed or something
and it's like, oh crap we
need to find another guy.
Like this sounds like
I'm getting stressed out,
they're messing all these moving parts.
- If it makes you feel
better, they're already there.
- Okay, okay.
- Yeah, they're already there.
These guys do that day in and night.
And to put it this way,
if there was someone that
was unable to come in
'cause they were sick or whatever,
the next person's just there.
- Okay.
- Right, right, right.
- Just wondering about
how this whole project.
- Okay, so in that case you're
hiring maybe not just a room,
but there'll be what's called a fixer,
an orchestral fixer.
- Who will help get 'em there.
- Who is like, they organize everything.
Cause you don't know
everyone, you really don't.
So you are coming into a situation where
you're hiring a service.
You're hiring the studio
and you're hiring,
more times than none,
I've seen that the studio
and the like musician hiring service
are one in the same-
- That makes more sense.
- They come hand in hand.
So if you're hiring the studio,
have you got musicians?
No.
Okay, use this person that fixes all our-
- Right.
- That makes sense.
- And then they'll say,
okay, well we need X amount of yay,
and we need X amount of
woodwind this and brass that.
And then let's say, you know,
someone doesn't rock up,
they just make a phone call
and I've seen it happen.
Like it's like, "Oh,
something didn't happen,
"can you come in?"
"Yep."
"Great, see you 10 minutes."
- Wow.
- Right, right.
- You just kind of like,
you can tailor the session.
Unless there's a request
for them to use their own conductor,
I always get my own stuff.
That way you have a lot more control.
I'm a bit control freaky so.
- Right.
- So I'm sure we all appreciate it.
- I figured that.
- Of course, of course.
- You all appreciate being
very, very anal about control.
- Yeah.
- But yeah.
Just like, let's say for example,
like you're missing a cello,
I'm just using example.
Say the cello, you know,
cellist falls down and you know-
- Explodes.
- Yes, let's go with that.
I was about to say something weird.
(laughing)
- You're about to say some real shit.
- I was like, blank.
- I could feel something
was coming out there.
- I was like, let's not go there.
No, sorry microphone.
So yeah, let's say like
cellist suddenly explodes,
just like Thanos snaps out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That was a good snap.
- That was a very good snap.
- I think that was a very good snap.
That was a firm snap.
- Ah, do you know why?
Conducting, 'cause you need
to go one, two, three, four.
- Then why were you
shocked by your own snap?
- Oh my God, I'm powerful.
(laughing)
- I can conduct.
- I have the power.
- [Lady In Background] This entire episode
is gonna win best tangent.
- Yeah.
- I'm sorry.
- WAAPAs
- What was I saying?
- Okay, so the cellist explodes.
- Conductor exploding.
- Cellist explodes.
Then you say, okay, let's
quickly switch over to like
just a violin and viola only
track for like 10 minutes.
Okay so we record that, great.
Finish that, welcome back cellist,
let's go back to that.
- Okay that makes sense.
- Right, right, right, right, right.
- You just have to keep
like working through it.
- You work in tandem with what's
called a session producer,
which is basically someone in the booth.
If there's not,
like the composer can
produce their own session
if they are hiring conductor to conduct.
But if you've decided to conduct yourself,
you work in tandem with the producer
or maybe two producers
in the booth saying,
"Yep, we've got that take.
"No, don't be a psychopath
about that, move on please"
sort of thing.
- Right, right, right.
- You can get in your
own head, especially-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Okay yeah, actually I
remember you saying like,
"Have we got it, have we got it?"
Like in a video when
you were talking about
how you have to, I think
you were on the scene,
it's like the boys club
or something like that.
And you were talking about
how you you're doing takes
or interviews and stuff
and then you're like, "Have we got it?
"Do we need to go again?"
Have like that sort of,
what would be the word?
Nervousness about, okay, co
we actually have the content?
Or do we not have the content,
do we need to go again?
And that-
- Right, it's important.
- Yeah.
But if you are filming it and you're also,
you know, in the shot,
then you've gotta go back
and and forth in that mind.
But having someone behind the camera,
or in this case, in the recording booth,
saying, "No, we got it,
it's chilled let's move on."
That kind of moves grease-
- It's like nice reinforcement.
- It's like, I guess, they should,
but like the cameraman,
he's like getting the shot,
but he doesn't necessarily give a shit
if it doesn't look great
sometimes, it depends.
- Okay, I would avoid that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I would recommend-
- And it's also, sometimes they don't know
what kind of shot that you want as like,
normally with a director-
- They don't have as much investment
as like say someone you
hire to be invested.
- Yeah, well, I mean, if you're
hiring a session producer,
they should, hopefully be invested.
- So you're hiring someone who's like
his job is to be as invested as you.
- Right.
- Yes, yeah.
- But obviously not everyone
will be as invested as you.
- Because otherwise he's
just a guy at the booth.
- No, I do see where
you're coming from now.
So there are times when
someone is just saying,
okay, have we got the,
you know, the standard?
- They'll be like, "Yeah, we got it."
- Yeah, we got it.
- Right.
- And then you go back and
you're like, you didn't have it.
- No, but then that would
maybe where experience kicks in
and you say, no, we're gonna go again.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- At the end of the day,
you're kind of driving the train.
Like people are really supporting you,
people are there doing their job,
but between you and maybe
like the music supervisor
or something like that,
you guys are driving that train
so you've gotta be like on it.
And this is where it's
not just a physical job,
it's also super mental
because you've gotta focus on not only,
especially if you're conducting,
you got the physicality of making sure,
okay, cue that person in,
keep on going like that.
You come in, you come in,
be three, blah, blah, blah.
You know, so you're cuing people
even though they can do it.
But you know, through the
physical act of conducting,
it's not just about keeping tempo,
which to be fair, everyone's
got a click in their ear
so it doesn't really matter too much.
But what it's about is coaxing
more performance out of it,
"More, more, more."
- Like, you're basically just like
micromanaging everyone, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Hopefully in like in a positive way.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah
- But it's like, for example,
if I'm going like this to you,
I'm like, okay, sing, sing, sing, sing.
And then okay, on that last
one then it's like sing more.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Sing.
- Do it again.
- Sounds a bit constipated,
but at the same time it's like, okay,
that should hopefully coax
a little bit more, you know,
you might push a little
harder or something like that.
So if you're doing that,
at the same time, you're also
listening to everyone else
in your headphones or like in the room,
making sure that everyone else
is playing at the same time.
So you're doing that over and over again
for nine hours a day.
- Yeah.
- So like you take everything
you just described,
how many more layers of difficulty
has been added on with COVID?
- I was gonna ask this.
- And having to do things remotely.
'Cause that sounds like
a nightmare in person.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there's a reason that
if you see me like in the room,
I'm like a sweaty mess
'cause it is like super intensive.
In the COVID times,
it's been interesting because
depending on where you are,
it's actually a little more convenient
in terms of the time difference
'cause obviously Australia is like
so far in front of everywhere, so.
If you're recording in
America it's quite nice
'cause you know, it's sort of
like an early morning thing
and I became a bit of an
early riser during COVID,
at least for a time until suddenly
I was very not an early riser.
But in Europe it's kind of interesting.
We did a lot of recording
in Prague, some Budapest-
- During the pandemic?
- During the pandemic
and for an upcoming project,
we did a little recording
in America as well.
- Right.
- But yeah, normally for
Europe it's normally like
an Australian nighttime sort of recording.
So you kinda of sit down at like
seven, eight o'clock at night
and then you do six, seven hours.
So you kind of finish
like two, three o'clock
in the morning.
- So you are on call.
- Yeah.
- With people who are just in a big hall?
- Yeah, so basically just stream the audio
on Audiomovers and Zoom.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
It's actually, to be honest,
like actually not bad.
- Really?
- But what if it like lags
halfway through like the recording, right?
- Cause like fucking
classic Australian internet
just crashes.
- Yeah, I was about to say,
I'm like, it must be shit.
- Yeah, it's like, cause yeah.
- Oh Kevin's connecting.
- Yeah.
- It's like, why is our
conductor in like 480p?
I can barely see him.
- At that point you're not
conducting unfortunately.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was what was really nice about
like going back to Sydney
for a couple of projects.
Sorry, going back to Sydney,
going to Sydney for a couple of projects
'cause like, yeah,
Melbourne Sydney is
like an hour and a half
on the plane and stuff
and that's pretty cool.
But yeah, to finally get back
to conducting for "Star Wars"
was really cool,
'cause that was the
first time I'd done it.
I forgot, 'cause the
muscles just like go away.
- To conduct?
- Yeah, cause like try doing this
for like nine hours.
- Right, yah.
- Like just the right arm.
- Just your right arm.
(laughing)
- You're like Quagmire, like.
- It's like what's up with your arm?
I'm a conductor, I swear I'm a conductor.
- We were talking about
carpal tunnel and "Jump King" before.
It's like that but for your entire arm.
Just like that.
- [Lady In Background] It's fine Garnt,
he's left headed so they balance.
(laughing)
- It balances out.
- Oh my God.
- Just post pandemic, and
he's just arms are huge.
- Perfectly balanced as
all things should be.
(laughing)
Yeah, I forgot how like
physically intensive it was.
So I was just sat like.
'Cause what you're normally meant to do
is like maybe be a little bit reserved
in like moving your arms and stuff.
- You can't help yourself?
- Yeah.
- But like you're getting into it,
fuck this up, this is fucking good.
That sort of thing and
then all of a sudden
you're moving your entire
body doing like Zumba
for like quite a few hours.
- Jesus.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's a little interesting.
- Sounds really intense.
- Yeah.
- So like speaking of, oh, sorry.
- No, no, I have nothing of value to say.
(laughing)
- Man's literally talked
for an hour and a half
and he was like, that was
all just bants bro, like.
- Literally just talking out of my ass,
none of that was real.
- Literally talking to-
- Time to wake up.
- Literally talking to
like an anime composer,
composed for some of the bigger shows
in like the past few years,
"I literally have
nothing of value to say."
(laughing)
- So "Star Wars".
- Yeah.
- How was that like?
- Really cool.
- How was it when like the
news came in to be like,
can you compose a piece of like
music for "Star Wars" media?
Cause I'm assuming like-
- Well it's a great honor.
You know, obviously it has
the history of history.
So "Star Wars: Visions"
is an animated series
based in the universe "Star Wars"
and I did one of those episodes,
it's nine episode.
Did the episode four
called "Village Bride".
And what I really liked about it is that
"Star Wars: Visions", our episode,
explored like some really
cool like spiritual
and biblical show.
- I was waiting for that one.
I was like, where is it, where is it.
(laughing)
- No, it explored some really
nice concepts with the force,
which was just, I mean,
I grew up watching that.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I watched the original
trilogy with my dad,
then my dad and I watched the prequels.
Then I did watch the
sequels as well, of course.
But yeah, it was really
nice to sort of have like
one hand in like sort
of that aesthetic world,
at the same time we're exploring
certain like spiritual aspects,
especially considering like the backdrop
is very like sort of Kyoto esque.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So like to have like the ability to use
like traditional Japanese instruments.
We used a Sho,
we used Koto,
we used Shakuhachi,
and we did a Shinobue as well.
- Right.
- And so we recorded those in Tokyo,
recorded orchestra in Sydney,
put 'em all together-
- It's crazy.
- Especially the Sho is a-
- Which one is that?
- Sho is the mouth organ.
I mean, I'm very, very
oversimplifying it to say that-
- I've never heard of this.
- Yeah, I know.
And then when Kevin
said it's a mouth organ,
I was this close to
being like, no, it's not.
(laughing)
- So you blow into like a
giant amount sort of like,
giant amount, thanks Kevin.
- Giant amount, a large amount.
- A large amount of bamboo
pipes and it creates-
- You've definitely seen it before.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- It's part of a temple culture a lot.
It's like, (humming)
I can't-
- right, right, right.
- I mean, you would've heard it,
you would've absolutely heard it.
But it's like 12 to 14 sort
of individual little pipes
and you blow into it,
you can blow in and out.
- Right.
- To create sort of a very, very-
- Yeah, this thing, this thing,
have you seen this thing?
- Oh, I've seen that, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, I have seen this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So it's a very complex,
very beautiful sort of cluster of notes
that create a very, very
dense, very specific,
oh and all these chords
have very, very, very special meaning.
So first off, obviously,
you know, as an Australian,
I really, really wanted to
be very careful about that
and you know, there's been,
I mean, there's always a bit
of an attitude in Australia
when it comes to using Australia's
indigenous instruments,
which is like you don't
want to fuck this up.
You don't want to be that person
that has really disrespected
a very, very important
and very sacred instrument.
- Yep.
- And so that mentality I've carried.
Like, I've been lucky enough to use
like sort of Australian
instruments in the past
and it's always been in
very explicit collaboration
with first nations people,
using those instruments
because I'm not gonna use
that instrument on my own.
Like I can't do that.
- Yeah.
- And so even though I am Australian,
I want to make sure
that when it comes to Japan's instruments,
it's the exact same approach.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Be very, very like
calculated in a good way.
Like sort of, you know,
talk to the musician,
saying what is okay, what isn't okay.
What are you happy with,
are you not happy with?
What is natural, what is unnatural?
Those sorts of things.
What are you happy with?
Thankfully, like the musician,
especially the Sho player is phenomenal
and was very, very, very open
to just sort of discussing,
okay, what does and doesn't work.
These are the chords,
like, these are sort of
the core chords so to speak
that you know, come on, like the,
yeah, it has like different systems.
It's very, very interesting.
So basically, you have like
different combinations of notes,
that they have like a different kanji
and it works actually on a circle,
it works on a, not a pendulum, sorry-
- Like a circle of
fifths type of thing or?
- Yeah, but not fifths,
it's a circle of chords,
but then all of them
have different meanings
and stuff like that.
I really hope I'm not
bastardizing this as well.
But like-
- I wouldn't know if you were.
- No, no probably I'd know.
- Yeah.
- I know you know.
- No, no, but basically
what happened is that
we did a lot of
workshopping and just said,
okay, how do we make sure
that like is this good?
Is this okay, is this not okay?
How, why and when sort of thing.
- Is that like, sorry,
'cause excuse my ignorance on this,
you're saying like, is that good
as in like, if you were
to use it incorrectly
it would be disrespectful?
- Well, it might not, like I don't know,
but the problem is I don't know.
- Right, right, right.
- And I'd rather like-
- You don't wanna overstep
the boundary just in case.
- Yeah, I'd rather ask too many questions
and just like be corrected,
or to be just said, "Nope,
don't worry about it.
"It's great, it's fine.
"Don't worry about it."
But that's not my permission to give.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So once I receive it, then I feel okay,
now we can record,
now we can actually, you know,
work with these instruments
and obviously like being
commissioned to do something
which is anime obviously style as well,
but like doing something that is anime
and in this case has a
very specific relationship
to Japan and its instruments,
that's super important for
me to make sure that like,
you know, I get that right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't wanna fuck it up.
- Yeah, of course.
- I really don't.
- Yeah.
- Is there ever like a difficulty
when you're working on a property
that has had so much
history and previous works
that you could kind of get
lost in inspiration with?
- I mean, yeah, it's not an easy one.
- Right, "Star Wars" has
a lot of music, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And a lot of the best music.
- Yeah so.
- 'Cause I guess you're
just like naturally gonna be
compared to the likes of
like John Williams, right?
So it's like, yeah.
But you don't wanna
sound too much like that.
- Yeah, but the thing is like,
'cause you have listened to it,
there's no way you can not listen to that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah,
- But like, I mean,
thankfully because it's anime,
because it's not live action,
we almost in a way had a
little bit more freedom
Because we were trying something new
and that was one of the ethos,
ethi?
- Ethos.
- That was the ethos of the show,
well at least, you know,
that was one of the,
sort of the core sort
of concepts of the show
was to, you know, obviously
be in the universe,
but then to explore it in
a medium that, you know,
I've been not only lucky
enough to be part of,
but I really do genuinely love.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's important.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause like I remember
like watching that episode
and I was just like of course,
I gotta support my boy, Kevin,
of course I'm gonna watch
"Star Wars: Visions."
And I remember like going to this episode
and I was just like,
this is like definitely "Star Wars",
but this is like such a Kevin "Star Wars".
I'm like, I don't know like, I'm not like
well versed enough in like musical lingo
to be able to like break down
what makes it a Kevin "Star Wars",
it just felt like a Kevin "Star Wars",
a Kevin take on the "Star Wars",
you know, universe and just, you know,
the iconic music as well.
- Is that something you do unconsciously?
Like you have a kind of
signature almost to your music?
- That's a good question,
I'm not actually even sure like, you know-
- I think regardless of whether
you like aim a do it or not,
I think you've achieved it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Do you think that when
people listen to your music
without knowing you or they
have heard your previous works
they can identify
another one of your work?
- Yeah, because actually
I didn't even know
that you did the music for that episode,
but as soon as like the
episode started playing,
I'm like, this is Kevin.
I already know, I know my boy.
- Yeah, I might gravitate
towards certain classic choruses,
put it that way.
- Yeah.
- I don't know,
I wouldn't know how to
put my finger on it.
I wouldn't know how to do that,
but I think in a way,
like it's both a very
endearing thing to hear
and at the same time I'm like,
okay, how can I not be.
- Yeah, how can I not do that.
- Next time I'll be like,
surprise motherfucker.
(laughing)
How can I do that next time?
So it's almost like,
it's a great thing to hear
and I am happy to hear it,
at the same time I'm like,
okay, I do eventually want to,
I feel like it sounds a bit fucking wanky,
but like I wanna evolve at some point.
- Yeah, of course.
- And like kind of transcend?
No, that's too far.
- You got a little too biblical, man.
(laughing)
- Plays the Russian synth.
- Well, I mean one-
- You have to evolve in every-
- Of course, of course.
- You gotta to stay on top.
- Yeah.
I mean, 'cause as we
were mentioning before
I just turned 30 and started
like putting together
like the list of, okay,
what do I want to do
in like the next 10 years?
Like what do I wanna do between 30 and 40?
And one of them is like just to
I wanna learn to sing again.
Cause I used to sing
and I used to not be totally shit at it,
and now I sound like,
I'm pretty sure like if like
- Bit outta practice.
- Yeah, let's just say
if like the cat was angry and screeched,
it would still sound better than
what my voice would sound
like if I attempted.
- You're being dramatic.
- You'll be fine.
- Like knowing you Kevin,
you're probably a lot
better than what you think.
- I think that's just your
musician side saying that.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, so like I wanna sing again.
I want to like-
- We gotta go to karaoke
to find out don't we?
- Oh God.
No, like singing and I wanna like kind of
try a few different musical ideas.
It would be really nice to
do like a personal album
for the first time,
like I've never really
released like a personal album,
like personal music.
- Right, right, right.
- So it's been in like
for the last, you know,
as far as I can remember,
like in terms of my professional life,
it's always been to a project
which is fucking awesome,
but at the same time I
feel like, you know what,
in the next 10 years it'll be good to like
really create something like-
- That's just you.
- Really just me.
I gotta figure out what that is as well,
'cause like, I don't know what I am, so.
- But welcome to being
in your 30s my friend.
(laughing)
- Good luck, good luck.
- Shit, I'm sweating.
- I got a little while,
I got a little while.
- Yeah, but no, no I'm-
- No like that's like,
you know, that's really
respectable though.
Like I think as you know,
because all of us right now
are in kind of the creative field,
regardless of if it's different
types of creative fields,
like, I think we can
all, you know, kind of,
you know, empathize with
that like feeling right.
I mean like yeah, you know,
you want to get yourself out there
and try and spread your wings out
as much as possible creatively, right?
- Yeah, I mean look how
much you've grown as well,
like look at your channel
and look at your content
and how it's developed,
and all three of you, for fuck sake.
I mean like look at this podcast.
I mean, last time we
caught up it didn't exist
and now it is this,
your personal channels as well,
we watch them all the time.
Like, we watch the old content,
watch the new stuff.
I mean, all of it's great,
but it is so lovely to see how
it has changed and evolved.
- Yeah, likewise man, likewise
- Thank you.
- Likewise with your stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm so sorry.
(laughing)
- Gentlemen, all men strive
for gold in their life, right?
Gold medals, gold
watches, gold everything.
However, there is a certain type of man
that goes the extra mile in life.
He walks with the confidence of an eagle
and giggles in the face of danger.
He's big, hairless and a winning machine,
and when he unzips his
pants he sees platinum.
That's right, Manscape would
like to introduce to you
their biggest, most ultimatest package,
the Platinum Package 4.0.
Join the 4 million men
worldwide who trust Manscape
by going to manscape.com for 20% off,
plus free shipping with code Trash Taste.
The Manscape brand new
Platinum Package 4.0
is the biggest bundle
they've ever offered,
giving you a bulk discount
on Menscape's top products.
That includes the Lawnmower 4.0 of course,
the Weed Whacker,
two in one shampoo and conditioner,
deodorant,
the Crop Preserver,
and also the Crop reviver,
and anti chafing boxes.
So if you want 20% off and
you wanna get free shipping,
use our coupon code trash
Taste at manscape.com.
That's 20% off plus free shipping
by using our coupon code
Trash Taste manscape.com.
Back to the episode.
- So I guess while we wrap this up,
I gotta ask like,
what do you want to explore next?
'Cause you always say you
wanna do something new.
What's like something
that you haven't done yet
that you want to do?
- Like musically speaking?
- Yeah, like musically speaking.
- I was going me for a second, yeah.
- Have a good Burger King burger.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We don't talk about the impossible here.
We have to go to the source.
Well, yeah, I mentioned like
the personal album thing.
I think what I want to do is expand,
which is the best way
to describe it, I think.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Like, you know,
I don't mean this in any sort of like
shitty braggadocios sort of way.
I am very happy with what I've
been able to achieve so far.
I mean I've turned 30 and
like these wonderful projects,
I met wonderful people,
I'm part of a wonderful sort
of industry and community,
you know, I've got friends
and family and all the sorts,
like I'm good,
I'm a happy boy.
- Yeah.
- I think balance, if anything,
is what I want to achieve next.
Yeah, I feel like, you know,
next is like, you know,
it's been like the pandemic can go suck
a massive fat bag of donkey dicks.
It fucking sucked.
But it put a lot of-
- Only bold statements.
(laughing)
- But you know, it did put a
lot of things in perspective
because like, you know,
you could work hard and hard and hard
and that's fine for a while.
Eventually like, you know,
not only does your body tell you,
like you know, you gotta
take better care stuff.
Like again, like I was mentioning,
I think maybe off camera,
but like yeah, I've put on
a fucking load of weight,
I drank too much,
I ate too much in the pandemic.
And like, it was just a way to deal
and fine we all kind of
get it it's not healthy.
- You weren't the only one.
- I feel like I'm like, yeah,
I'm not breaking any fucking-
- So you did what?
- I think the statement is gonna come
as a massive shock now,
it was fucking down during the pandemic.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- I'm very not unique to that.
I was not that happy all the time.
So yeah, I think the one thing that I've,
you know, coming into
quote unquote, "endemic"
end of pandemic which-
- Endemic.
- Is that what everyone's calling this?
- Is that a thing now?
- Is this an Aussie thing?
- No, it's called optimistic.
- Optimism, optimistic.
- Optimism, fuck optimism.
So yeah, I'm optimistically
calling it endemic,
and I'm calling it that because like,
I'm sat here now, I'm on the show.
- That's not an Aussie thing by the way,
that's a Kevin thing.
- It's like, let it be so.
- Yeah.
- But like I'm really
keen to like just kind of
get life back and just
feel fucking as normal
as best as possible.
Like, you know, I want like the day to day
to be really productive at the same time.
I live in Melbourne now.
I moved back to Melbourne
because I really wanted to be
closer to community and family
and fuck, I missed Australia
so much when I was living here
and that's why I moved back.
- Yeah.
- But you know, Melbourne's
like a beautiful city to be in,
even though we had all these
crazy lockdowns and stuff,
like I'm really happy there,
it's a beautiful base.
But it is nice to just
fuck off and go to Japan,
and go to America,
and go to London,
come to London, I should say.
Like, so you know, that almost is like,
it's such a pleasure to be here right now
because it is a bit of a recharge
and there are some countries
that still can't do that.
So you gotta really take it, you know,
you gotta really think of it,
right now, pretty lucky in the context
of the fact that we are going through
a fucking pandemic still.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So yeah, balance is what I wanna achieve
between, you know, lifestyle, friends,
professionality, work ethic,
work quality as well like obviously.
I dunno how the, you know,
it'd be nice to potentially
go back to school.
Like not like school school, but like,
you know, I've tried
learning Korean a little bit
and still trying that,
yeah, I've had to kind of, you know,
pick my battles in terms of
trying to like learn more stuff.
And I like the idea of just
trying to expand a little bit
and try different things.
Tried a little bit of
streaming in like mid 2020,
or like late 2020, a
little bit of middle 2021.
I kind of like put it on the back burner
because I just got really,
really busy with, you know,
some of these projects and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I do miss that.
I miss the streaming, it's good fun.
You know, just like live composing
or like playing all games, you know.
I wanna play "Metroid
Prime" if it comes out.
- Hell yeah.
- Played "Eco" on stream,
that was really, really fun.
Wanna play "Shadow Of The Colossus"
and all that sort of.
Like that's a fun thing to experience.
- All games that have amazing music.
(laughing)
- This is why I like them.
Yeah, I was like, yeah.
You know, just like playing games
that like are really
important to me on stream,
or like composing music in
front of a live audience,
it almost like activates
a different part of
the brain a little bit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I guess you could relate it to like
content creation offline and online.
- Right, right
- Live, I should say.
- Yeah.
- So yeah expansion and
balance I think is yeah.
- Expansion, it sounds like such a.
Yeah, I'm British, you know that word.
- I will the expand.
- Yeah, I mean, I like
we've wanted to have you on
since basically like the
beginning of the podcast-
- But like, who would be
the most perfect guest
for a show like this?
The mate Kevin.
- Our mate Kevin.
- I have some bad takes for you.
I can commit.
- And we've had like-
- So bone and chicken?
- Oh fucking boneless, man, come on.
- Yes.
- Come on. Yes.
- That's good.
- I'm sorry.
- That's my boy.
- You have Korean fried chicken,
do you want bone in chicken
or do you want like a fucking-
- I'm leaving, this is
like, you know what,
it's been a fantastic episode.
We'll bond together, we'll bond together.
- Look, I appreciate that
you've come to terms a
little bit better on bread.
I do respect that you are getting better.
- Just as a person.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm just saying that,
what do you want to achieve in your 30s
and why is it boneless?
(laughing)
- I want to expand.
- The expansion.
- World domination.
- It's the 30s expansion,
what can I say, man?
But yeah, I mean like,
we've like had to, I guess
like fucking move mountains
to get you on because we're
not filming in Australia,
we're not filming in Japan,
we're filming in fucking the UK.
You know, which neither
of us even live in.
- It's a weird detour.
- Yeah definitely.
- It's weird detour,
but it's nice that we are able
to make this happen, finally.
- Absolutely,
- Finally.
- Hey, like hopefully
like when Japan decides not to, you know-
- Yeah mate.
- Please come.
Please come back because
we've gone two hours
and somehow we've not talked about
Oolong High or Oolong Die.
But you're going to, by the way that's-
- That's the next time.
- This is the sober conversation.
This is like the pre convo.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Next time you come up, we have to-
- Second episode is gonna be Oolong High.
- Yeah, that's the thing,
this is almost like, you
know, this is the season one.
This is the conversation
we should have had in the old studio,
now we've gotta come to the new studio.
- Yeah.
- And like-
- And just get fucking hammered.
- We've done one core, now we do two.
1.5% more alcohol.
- Hell yeah.
- But yeah, I guess we'll leave
it there for the time being.
You know, obviously we're
gonna get you back eventually
in Japan, hopefully,
with a little bit more booze
and little bit more bants, yeah.
- Absolutely, of course.
- But hey, in the meantime-
- We'll try not to talk
about fucking synthesizers
for like three hours.
- Oh mate.
- We've only talked-
- Let's see which ones I
get between now and then.
- Well we'll hear your top 10
synthesizers list pretty soon.
- I've got a list.
I've got a fucking list, man.
Actually, do you not know what, no.
- Tell me off camera, tell me off camera.
- Yeah, I was gonna tell you over dinner.
- But hey, look at all
these patrons though.
These amazing, lovely patrons,
look at 'em Kev,
look at 'em just floating by.
Oh my God, so many of them.
- Who's your favorite patron?
- Who's your favorite?
- That one, that one, that
one, that one, that one.
All done Murdoch.
(laughing)
- I was like god dammit.
But Hey, if you like to support the show,
then go over to our patron
on patron.com/trashtaste,
also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the sub Reddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify
and hey, go check out Kev's stuff.
Wait, is there anything you
wanna shout out by the way?
- I do the Twitter's
and obviously like "Made In
Abyss" is coming up in July.
- Which I'm so fucking pumped.
- Oh yeah, we didn't talk
about "Made In Abyss 2".
- Maybe next time, maybe next time.
- Maybe next time.
- It'll be out hopefully like
next time we like hang out
so we can finally talk
about it in depth, so.
- Yeah, we've got a
couple of things going,
but most of them, yeah.
It's like think of it as like,
there's like a little
pinpoint on your head
with a sniper rifle at the end of it,
and you know, you're just like,
"Oh, I'm gonna talk about".
- Yeah, it just doesn't happen.
- I'm ready to be depressed.
- Hey, welcome to the club buddy.
(laughing)
♪ Hello darkness my old friend ♪
- Well, yeah, thanks for coming on Kev.
- My pleasure, thank you to all,
and on the final note I just wanna say
thank you to all three of you
both personally and you know,
it's been nice.
- Right, right, what a lad.
- What a lad.
- What a fucking lad.
- Well that's why he's our boy.
- Fucking lad.
- Love you all, thank you.
- That's our mans right there.
- It's the most wholesome ending
to a "Trash Taste" episode ever.
- Thank you for doing what you do.
- Yeah, of course, likewise.
- Sorry I'm getting a little.
- Are ya?
- Fuck I'm gonna cry now.
- You wanna cry?
- Thank you for helping
both of us through this
'cause it's been a really bad pandemic.
It's nice to-
- Aw.
- Sorry, I don't know.
- Come here, aw.
- Sorry, I feel like, maybe
if I got like fucking drunk
(speaker drowned by laughing)
I didn't expect it to be like sober,
but seriously, thank you
for doing what you do,
it really helps.
- Yeah.
- It's really nice every
Saturday to come like wake up
and watch "Trash Taste",
it's lovely to see your content.
- We will try.
- So thank you for doing what
you do 'cause it does help.
- Yeah, man.
- Likewise man.
- Lots of love, lots of love.
- Likewise.
- Mate for life man, mate for life.
I'm just happy that we're
gonna hang out again, man.
I'm so fucking happy, man.
- Fuck, can I please have a drink?
(laughing)
- That's the end.
- All right bye.
(gentle music)